we welcome you back to the I am not GM
speech s Championships brought to you by
chess calm another quarterfinal matchup
awaits us here between international
masters Teddy Coleman International
Master Laimbeer Osmond and the
questioned has at the top of everyone's
mind is levy Danya who does the better
impressions between you two should I
should I answer that or is please
because I think we all know the answer
and that is levy oh I was gonna say
Daniel okay we're starting we're
starting nice and I think I think Daniel
and I have a degree of overlap but
there's some that he does that are just
exceptional like when he when he does
his kramnik I'm like you know it's like
we watching his candidates interviews
where every game he was claiming he was
winning
I was completely vegan like I can't even
do it like well there's too much respect
this is not what we're here for
anxiety did you a full day of work today
before getting ready to play some speed
chess I did work this morning but I took
off the afternoon took a full nap so you
know feeling ready to go so you know
just sounded like you know you know
you're ready for three hours of intense
chest three hours of chest is always a
long time but yeah I feel I feel like
I'm ready to go and let me worry about
you what did you do to prepare for
today's matchup I was I'm not gonna lie
like I was this whole thing's been
pretty awesome like I I watched the
whole last match I was in the Chad teddy
if you reread the Chatham I'm sorry I
was uh I was bantering with with my
haters you know as the cool kids say and
I you know III like the second my
opponent had a name I was grinding like
since then like I've been playing blitz
bullet non-stop I've been doing like you
know one plank a day kind of nonsense so
I could get in shape so I won't tell you
how long I do the plank for but well
Teddy you had a first-round matchup
against a very obscure opponent I don't
think anybody in the chat really knows
that person's name was Danny something
so questions but you were question for
you what kind of adjustments did you
make from that fascinating thrilling
match what sort of modifications
what lessons did you learn then you hope
to apply in this match today yeah I
think from the match it was a pretty
obvious that of the three segments that
the bullet was definitely the one where
I struggled the most in so definitely
also just like trying to practice my
bullet try to get a little bit more
comfortable in the faster time control
you know that's definitely was my
biggest takeaway is that the match is
really long really hard and but the the
bullet segment is just a killer at the
very end of it for sure and levy
any final thoughts as we let you two get
settled before your match let's no no
trash don't want you to get excited I
don't want you oh no no I mean I mean
you know there was this there was a big
talking point like you know the bullet
between you know Teddy and then Danny
was like crazy fun and chaotic and
everything but I mean frankly speaking
in my opinion if you're not a GM and
you're really good at bullet you're just
an online degenerate you know Teddy just
has better priorities than playing
bullet on the internet for for long
periods of time so if you adjusted for
time spent and I'm sure he'd also be
twenty six twenty seven hundred but he
has better priorities in life so Wow
well both said we'll let you two get
your priorities in order and we will
take a short break and when return the
matchup will start and everybody can
watch Teddy and Levy do get out of the
chessboard we'll be right back
[Music]
and we look across the bracket we saw
Ali Nikesh and Skye defeat Eric Rosen
earlier today who will she face in the
next round will it be
Teddy Coleman will it be levy Rosman
Donna you know I always put you on the
spot who do you think is taking this
battle between Teddy and levy well I'm
gonna learn from my previous mistakes
I'm not gonna prevaricate and I'm just
gonna go with levy as the favorite here
I feel like I always say this but
experience is critical here and levy a
veteran him online chest using
incredibly strong bullet player will get
to those comparisons in a moment but I'm
gonna have to go with levy here ya know
what can you tell me about levies
various ratings and experience levels I
mean just look at those ratings they
speak for themselves
2705 in blitz 27:52 in Bullitt and he
doesn't want to see mayhem reach Gotham
because Teddy Coleman is strong I mean
what could you tell us about Teddy's
play well Teddy of course living right
now in the Bay Area my hometown and
don't be fooled by Teddy's lits rating
in a bullet rating that is his bullet
rating is pretty low but he is going to
make adjustments this match he's going
to learn from his last match against
Danny and of course this blitz is very
very solid he's a very strong player in
classical as we saw in his match against
Danny wrench he is very very sound
fundamentals so that is going to propel
him forward in this match and I think
it's gonna make it a very very close one
I think you're right and for Teddy I do
think he needs to get out to a strong
start in the blitz because the bullet
he's a shaky last time but he ultimately
was able to win in that tiebreaker
but levy is a whole nother level right
now levies been working his tail off
increasing his ratings he's over 2,700
and both blitz and bullet and like I
said that those numbers speak for
themselves Danya he's very strong he
determined and I think that like Teddy
really has stood out draw it start
indeed and and we should also keep an
eye on levees opening preparation which
i think is gonna be nothing short of
superb as many of the people in Chatham
Trevor no levy recently released an e4
course he's very very booked up and in
blitz
bullet that means a lot if you could
blitz out a lot of these opening moves
and and the critical thing is getting
the game into positions that fit your
style
if levy can do that consistently that's
going to put him with an edge in the
smash so Teddy's gonna have to deal with
that and Teddy's going to have to step
it up in the bullet section because Levy
isn't incredibly fast and strong
inexperienced bullet player and off they
go the first game and here we are
leve Rosman the higher seeded player
gets the white piece and when I say
higher seat it's kind of lower C's
always weird terminology we're talking
about Braxton seating and the triangle
by Teddy Wow I don't think I've seen who
play the triangle ever I witness let me
play the square oh my gosh okay one
second is it Teddy Coleman actually
playing with the black pieces to me that
shows some real preparation by Teddy
because I'm not used to him playing he's
hyper aggressive highly theoretical
Lions and he's playing through
ninety-six very quickly so the point is
Bishop f8 you're hitting g7 do not take
that Bishop on that mission on f8 you
get checkmated with Queen to d8 and now
Teddy thinking here not really the right
time to think after your opponent throws
inhibition of faith plays in that you
see seven call just gathering his
bearings giving up the g7 pawns show
that one more time
that if you took on that faith Queen d8
his check this is all opening theory is
really R stuff yeah yeah it was not a
chess calm which there was not a black
Bishop that was supposed to be on that
fate this is a move that has been played
for years now very well studied but I am
just as surprised as you are oh but I
thought maybe Teddy changed his name to
Wesley Coleman or maybe Gary Coleman
because this is an incredibly
theoretical line we saw Teddy try to
leave theoretical waters against Danny
has he bitten off more than he can chew
here I honestly don't know these lines
very well but the move Knight up five
seems tempting either now or in the next
move and I'm not sure Knights e2 or 93
you have all these checks and that's
what gets confusing if you study online
but haven't really really deeply studied
it you get to a position like this and
you freeze because like wait a second
Knight a5 looks like it could be right
my easy to check looks like it could be
right 93 check also looks interesting
and then you're spoiled for choice in
the sense when in reality it
cuz of the difficulty of this position
there may be only one right answer and
so levy he's playing quickly 93 check
happened he has some who was king there
goes a d2 and now Knight a5 offering a
queen trade on d3 and at the end of it
yes
white temporarily wins a piece but loses
the bishop on g7 we get to an end game
and I think this is the right choice by
Teddy absolutely I don't see an
alternative for levy other than to take
on d3 I briefly considered the crazy
line Knight g3 but I have a very hard
time believing that works and here we
see the transition I mean at most I
think levy has a very small advantage
due to blacks you know slightly
defective King side pawn structure but I
just don't see you know I think Teddy is
still breathing a sigh of relief he has
an end game that he can work with he
likes these types of positions he's very
good in this type of maneuvering game
even if he slightly worse objectively
yeah and this move e5 opening up squares
for this Bishop on see that's the
problem piece if you had not put a 5
which is a quite a risky move to some
degree because when you push the pawn
forward that pond won't easy to attack
but now the bishop has life it can go to
e6 then I can go into f5 and another
benefit planky 5 look and then Knight
only 2 upon 3 squares from away for a
night often dominates that night and
rook e1 plate so that it was like f4
even Knight f4 Knight d4 are possible
because the King is in the center so
there's a pin here and good mm-hmm
sorry - no no you call your attention
when you're about to make a point but
when you look at an endgame like this
how great are what chances or do you
think black should inevitably be ok here
well I was about talking about just that
so your question is is well opposed I
think I do think that white is slightly
better here I have a hard time believing
that that blacks defective pawn
structure that pawn on e5 means nothing
to put it in twitch terminology when I
look at the pawn on e5 my first reaction
is Makkah s because 94 now 4 is the
threat f4 immediately is very annoying
Teddy's got a lot of problems to solve
we see his time situation levy up almost
a minute
I feel like probably White's advantage
of ejected Lee speaking is not huge if
black defends accurately but now that I
look at this for longer I feel like
there's a lot of latent pressure on
blacks position which Teddy is going to
have to solve
in f6 is probably the tempting move this
to reinforce the Pawnee 5 but then
looking right away at f4 trying to hand
black an isolated pawn in the center of
the board and it came out c3 don't
underestimate that king because people
say whoa whoa whoa this isn't king of
the hill what's this King doing out here
in end games the king can come become an
aggressive attacking piece and if you
think about it at some point if the
rooks get traded is king going to be 4
and start marching forward on the Queen
side so f6 played by Teddy I'm looking
at at 4-4 Le'Veon perhaps f4 is met with
E 4 I don't know it feels a bit flimsy
and I'm struggling a little bit tell you
just castles King side
ofE and Knight G 30 looks looks quite
sensible I mean of course let the Teddy
could give away the 5 funnies not gonna
be completely lost but in addition to
that bond why it's just as you mentioned
that King on c3 is very well positioned
yes the King let's see there he is
excellent piece and the pawn on e5 is a
clear target it's just out in the open
there's a brook anyone but what is a bit
underdeveloped on the Kings side you're
on f1 your rook on h1 the black rook
will gain access along the F file so
here we have seen the capture and I'm
almost wondering of a move like night of
5 is smart here giving away the e5 pawn
but then turn the double white spawns in
return so if Knight a5 let's say you
take on e5 I take on g3 and then I put
my like Bishop f5 at the end and I say
hey this extra pawn here is not really
an extra pawn because you can't create a
pass on as the endgame takes shape
yeah I think that's a that's a good
defensive idea man at the end of that
line I can try c5 with the idea of
Bishop c4 but I do think the black can
hold things together there if he's
careful maybe we're okay to e8 after
that covering the e7 square and rookie 7
can be met with rook f7 so it's not
going easy to penetrate I the more I
look at this position Robert the more I
feel like mattified Mikey Black's only
serious defensive chance because we're
rocky 8 I think is that's just got to be
too passive especially with a knight
that might come to e4 yeah that Knight
gets the e4 especially the rook in the
8th you're threatening a fork on the f6
square and the d6 square was vulnerable
now not if I played by Teddy a very good
practical choice in the position and if
I'm levy I'm scooping up that ePHI pawn
and think about the consequence after it
it sound like Black has any tactic to
take advantage
I'm just making the claim that your
extra pawn is a double pawn but it still
isn't etched upon and white rook and I
say plural rooks are more active the
rook on h1 suddenly becomes an extremely
active piece
is he gonna cook t5 check and pick up
the night this way cuz he stopped here
uh-huh
I didn't notice that idea to start no he
decides to take on g3 now very important
to play Bishop f5 otherwise the bishop
comes out to d3 and Teddy does so and
you called the entire thing and rumor
has it you're pretty good at chess
robbery that from but that rumor seems
to be confirmed though I think that this
was definitely Teddy's best try and I'm
not quite seeing how white breaks there
your move c5 with great intentions of
Bishop c4 check and if we play sieve out
I think Rick 88 as you mentioned Bishop
c4 King to g7 and if you play rook to HD
you want to trade on the e5 script but
like King on f6 and say I mean who's
really made more progress here not the
black King right it was the white king
in terms of activity yeah the black king
is like Alexander griffith thug life in
north my king was on June 8th ins and
they brought the to f6 and all of a
sudden I was Union
but now rock f7 as we discussed him and
as you mention Robert it still is an
extra pawn and an extra pawn is an extra
pawn but you know that those pawns on
the G file are not the same thing as if
white would have had you know and have
fun and achieve fun so I'm not sure what
Teddy is deciding between I don't see an
alternatives to rook up 7 to you he
might finger over 88 giving up the
b-pawn he had a rookie 3 check in the
activity sometimes an end games you give
up a pawn maybe even two pawns for
enormous activity but here I don't like
the move rook Adia I just don't feel
comfortable giving up the Queen side
pawns especially considering his time
disadvantage ready yeah so what I was
trying to rook d1 and pin this bishop
but aha i against Bishop e2 then he
wants to play Rukia it's very creative
Wow does it work Teddy
operating outside of the normal Teddy
framework that I know and right now Rick
a to d8 threatens rook to d1 but now c5
just happens right now in this position
and he does so and now rook d7 is
possible oh my god
we both saw it we both were saying it
with hh7 you distract the bishop you
wing the brook and their teenage shades
King h8 him this is not the way but in
Bishop c4 anyway yeah oh and then route
e7 still not possible same thing so King
h8 played and now now that's about
Bishop c4 and I wonder if the bishops
before this b5 like I protect both of my
7th rank pawns by a counter threat on
this bishop on c4 and the bishop needs
to stay protecting the d3 square
otherwise black goes rook t3 check true
although maybe Bishop e6 there can be
considered rook t3 and then even king c2
because I have those made threats that's
exactly what happens but that has to be
calculated concretely because y can also
get made it if you try Bishop e6 route
III King before 54
you can't run to a5 you're gonna get
checkmater than I for it just shows you
can never relax any kind of endgame as
long as there's any material you cannot
sleep on your king you certainly cannot
and actually efficiently 6 I would be
worried about getting pin to race the
kind of rook d3 rook III just pinning
that bishop on e6 so this is a tough
moment for levy he's actually down on
the clock now
all credit to levy for seizing the
advantage early this game and credit to
Teddy for really putting up stubborn
resistance and unorthodox ways with this
work a to d8 and now b5 and let me know
to 20 seconds yeah but he's no much
better Oh a fight he's gonna check -
Jack made him he wants to funds before
ideas and levy can't move his vicious
Bishop is now literally peg to peg to D
3 because roof d3 is just devastating
otherwise and Bishop g6 triangle rook F
2 now the other extreme sin
wow what are no of events here it looked
like White's works were getting
activated all of a sudden it's black and
looked at time for three oh my gosh he
barely got them but watch out rook takes
just hanging because the pawn a7 is
pinned to the king you could play rook F
- I think it's who you're gonna say
exactly and trade try to trade bishops
you lose g6 for e - that actually looks
very interesting rook e8 similar idea
but now but ship f3 I don't like that
move at all
I feel like Katie should have brought
all those chips to the center of the
table especially with a sign situation
now levies King relatively safe that
pawn on c6 although King t4 and King e5
I just don't see it here rook d3 King e5
bishop
you think's whose pawn is better oh look
at the time look at the time he's gotta
have a second beat four oh my god you
possibly have yeah that was Oh any proof
that was a bad dream of buy levy oh gosh
let's finish d5 my goodness maybe rook
did you check my sex Eddy yeah rook
teachers played Bishop defines Bishop
somebody throws in a two now and now you
with Bishop f7 and try to get that rook
to be one but he has five seconds now I
mean this is anybody's game six Bishop
c4 b 1 c 7 oh my god first you should
have played c 7 at first i think that
was actually might have been winning for
white well we'll take a look after this
game concludes right now it looks like
teddy he takes the bishop and the h pawn
matches the bishop so that is an
important note even if the king somehow
can get all the way back whoa wait a
minute is this this is gonna be very
closer over is it no you just oh my gosh
wait a second Bishop e7
oh but she be savage from g4 to g4 and
then the King has to move away from the
h-bomb wait he doesn't see it what see
what's he doing what is he doing no oh
my god she just didn't see Bishop g4
here and we are gonna analyze this
position as that game came down to the
stretch there Wow Teddy Coleman misses
an opportunity to pool in the position
after either a Bishop e7 q g5 Bishop g4
the King cannot stay attached to this
each part would have to move to on the
sixth rank and then you take the pawn on
G to bring your King back marcher pawn
home and well Donny had a point earlier
that the C pawn wrong move order the
rook e1 c7 first that way you have to
stop see it equals Queen to Bishop e6
then Brooke takes a 2 and the bishop
cannot capture on a 2 while still
protecting against the Queen so that was
Miss opportunities for both the various
moments in that game a draw was reached
and now Teddy with the white pieces look
at his pawn center here pawns on d4 and
e4 and Danya I hate Knight to c6 they're
in front of pawns and c7 and did and I
just should point out Teddy in that last
game also sacked his rook for that bond
I think a little bit prematurely
he did this a couple of times against
Danny where he he tries to choose sort
of the safe option but sometimes that
lessens the margin of error and it
backfires I like the way he's starting
out
here bravely occupying the center Queen
a4 now is of course threatening Queen
sex before
now the center is both the blessing and
a curse if lively can find a way to
consolidate Teddy could experience you
know some anxiety connected with those
e4 and d4 pawns but I don't see how to
do that
yeah isn't white just stealing a pawn he
was 92 very quickly so it's Teddy still
I mean sixer no I mean a key to also you
didn't want to see this is what you're
saying though that he could have just
taken this pawn on c6 but he was
probably working some kind of a bishop
takes f3 and his King may not find true
shelters of Teddy does have his tendency
to avoid complications in some moments
and we saw that backfire in the first
game when he gave up his rook Larry
early which are still winning for him
but then when he has four seconds left
he couldn't find the the knockout and
now with the white pieces we've loved
his position he's up over a minute on
the clock great preparation but let's
say here c5 Bishop made three yeah the
result of trying to trying to you know
play more safely as often times
ironically the position gets more
complicated and here this is a big step
forward for levy in terms of improving
his pawn structure
I feel like Teddy hasn't made the most
of this position cdcd and of course why
it is undeniably still clearly on top in
the driver's seat but levy can defend
you can play Queen d7 tried try to go
for a queen trade those opposite colored
bishops they've occurred a lot in the
morning match between Alina and Erik and
and with the Queen's off the board they
lend more of a draws tendency to the
position yes
and now Bishop g6 going after the e4
pawn so that's gonna be the issue that
taze me figure I would probably put f3
here I know that looks like a week in
some of the dark squares but you're the
only player with the dark square bishop
and if I go f3 I can play Knight b3 next
and I can avoid c5 and that's a critical
point black would love to play c5 get
rid of one of the ugly isolated Queen
side pawns but if you're unable to do so
especially after Knight to b3 look at
your Bishop on g6
you see that this pawn chain from g2 to
e4 strangles this Bishop there's no
active squares for that piece and same
with the knight and f6 we always talk
about as a pawn three squares away from
a knight here the pawn on f3 Brimley
takes away this night as access and the
pony for it is the same taking away the
d5
so this has to be good for waiting look
at the two minute timing believable
actually at two minutes is among the
most lopsided time situation we've seen
in the five minutes section yeah so
that's crucial what is black do here
Queen d7 was one move that you suggested
then this Queen c4 just avoiding the
Queen trade and then playing Bishop a3
to follow at some point just you know
getting a tempo in the brook yeah I mean
you've got a you've got to basically
choose an approach either you're gonna
hunt for an endgame or you're gonna hunt
for four c5 opportunities but levy is
kind of freezing here and you know this
is this time situation is getting very
alarming because two and a half minutes
very significant he's trying to massage
those g3 so I think he's trying to
prepare have five I like that idea
actually of basically throwing all of
your trips into the Kings side and
saying alright if this works you know he
might actually have a chance to turn the
tables I like this move Knight h5 yes I
mean you have to do something like that
to take advantage of the exposed dark
squares on the white king sided Bishop
a3 using an open diagonal then that
night can go into f4 so that's something
that Teddy avoids apply Knight to b3 and
f5 here a very double-edged move because
I'm one hand you're freeing the bishop
it looks better you're trying to attack
the white center I'm gonna hand you this
pawn on e6 I can quickly become a real
target yeah and we'll see how he handles
this I mean again levy experiencing some
indecision here this time advantage
getting close to three minutes and he
goes for Queen h4 he's piling up on the
kingside Teddy's got to be careful
because oftentimes you get so enthralled
with pressuring the flank that you have
an advantage on that your pieces get
marooned there and then all of a sudden
you don't realize how weak your King is
so Teddy's got to be a little bit
precise here maybe I'm overstating
blacks down a play but I just feel a
little bit you know the pings of anxiety
here when I look at blacks King your
move f5 really could have hurt White's
position but I think Bishop e3 is a
smart move now even buddy five say what
did you really again yes your Bishop is
improving yes you're looking like you
might create some trouble on my Kings
side but the bishop can always slide
back to f2 where it safeguards the King
and in fact if you play e5 now if black
ever plays f4 that's the square the
knight wants to get to so that's the
struggle that black is working with here
is playing f4 freeze
Bunji six but takes away a possible
square for an attack for black yeah so
after e5 there's obvious there there is
that dilemma for sure does Teddy have
any alternatives to e5 I don't see any
because allowing F take C force just
doesn't seem to make much sense I mean
it takes f5 neither does that because
black gets the best of all of the worlds
after Bishop takes f5 yes then White's
left for this isolated deep on which is
well protected and Teddy wants to play
brook c1 get after the c7 pawn but when
there's your center is under attack and
in some peril ie five just feels like
the smart safe teddy like move and I'm
really imperious what he's contemplating
here well you're the appointed reader of
Teddy's facial expressions having known
him for so many years Robert so maybe
you can help translate if you look at
look at Teddy's expression what is it
that he's thinking about is he nervous
he's probably thinking about a line of
code that he needs to work on after this
speech Chess Championship magic but you
know when I look at Teddy's face right
now he's really deep in thought hey
there he plays a five he's in a minute
in 24 seconds to play that move and
that's a move that he certainly saw
instantly like 'if I've was probably the
first one that went through his mind and
after night g3 there's even bishop f2 I
can say hey what's your at night doing
here that's a pin on that night you
can't take my room because you're Queens
under attack he plays rook e1 he's just
you know I like the way he's playing and
Bishop to will come and do time from A
to C one is next yeah black still has
all the weaknesses in the position but
what about f4 Bishop f5 when Bishop
takes h3 I feel like that's that's okay
queen chief I'd buy levy I'm not sure
about Queen g5 I felt like Bishop f5
might have actually been quite nasty
yeah five now again ambitious takes h3
still in the picture I think what she
goes kh2 and it does look a little scary
but with the King on h2 somehow you're
defending the pawn on h3 there's no sort
of Knight moves that end up hurting the
White King and this pawn on f4 is one of
those pawns work you both like it and
hate it as black because you would like
to throw it off the board and go net h5
night at 4:00 it's just funny how
sometimes you want to capture your own
pieces you have very well said and
speaking of chess expression and Teddy
spent that you know amount of time on on
e5 I was reminded of
see I don't remember who first raised it
I've heard it from my friend Grandmaster
Sam Shanklin that you know 90% of the
time you know what move you're gonna
make after 1520 seconds and the time you
spent thinking is to justify to yourself
that you're actually doing the due
diligence 9701 are to repeat - yes
levy what a tricky guy if b1 is covered
syrupy were not possible this I'm
telling you this starts to look once
again monka is the word that comes to my
mind he's trying to take on e6 but I'm
not sure that helps after rugby - what
is he intending after E - yeah that
looks a bit scary because rook B - he
can't even protect his Bishop on f2
maybe he'll take on E okay rook be 296
Bishop e6 Queenie sashayed King and King
to g1 haha 20 guy at a little bit that's
me because Bishop g1 there's Knight f1
check that's a filthy little checkmate
after king - on maybe 92 and back to g3
is that some sort of repetition so after
which we start Queenie sixth King h8 now
King g1 when we were you looking at 90 -
check
yeah and then repeating it to g3 but Ivo
38 I'm just not sure about that because
now you know the avid Main Street is
closed off and the roca no longer get to
be - and the 12 seconds somehow levy is
just down on the clock in all of these
games and rook c1 going after the c7
pawn even more and you could have taken
on c7 right away but then the Brooke
came to see it down to see - so Teddy
it's just closing off all opportunities
for Liberty much d5 isn't moving I'm
considering for white cuz yeah I'm
opening up the position White's king is
the one that's been looking vulnerable
that black King if I open up the
position your King on Jake might be in
some trouble itself definitely and you
know other than g5 maybe Teddy is just
hunting for the bonds there Queen takes
a seven he might have look at the time
so - oh I thought he blundered nt7 I'm
crazy myself but Queen c6 I mean it's
hard to say whether there's any imminent
danger to the white king I don't see any
tactical ideas for levy so as long as
this structure remains stable there's
some sort of uneasy peace that that's
going on between blacks pieces and
whites King but as you say maybe g5 is
the way to go because I just don't see
any other way to make progress on the
Queen side and I actually really liked
the Queen on a 5x3 meant c5 because it
protect the bishop on f2 so when you go
d5 just in case and Bishop g6 like
quickly by levee and can you just take
on a6 there he goes and is don't go d5
just yet but I wanna play d5 and now
defy the threat
so he goes Bishop f7 because 95 it's
possible she knows the g3 square for the
Queen with the bishop
so Ruchi 1 your Bishop takes age for
critical me 1 play rogue chew up his
Bishop h4 okay goes Bishop h4 but now
Queen g3 check and ABI and you're just
saying okay it's fine yeah I guess so
I guess it is but I don't see six fish
no f7 that exactly it's a trap so don't
you don't want to that I would play
Queen c3 Queen e1 I would just go to
trade those Queens and say mine item b3
is excellent protecting my pawn on d4 it
was a forties try to get a queen over
there
levy trying to get I'm trying to snap on
h3 that's a semi threat I'm not sure it
is that I would definitely play Queen C
3 now wait c3 protect the f3 pawn that's
a very important point and then you
threaten Queen to e1 to charge those
Queens off and actually a4 is a risky
move because I remember 3 doesn't
protect her
so this rook and f8 can swing to b8 and
your queen may be overloaded very
shortly yup and after Queen see if your
Bishop h-street 0.10 but now takes a
bishop h3 okay where makes 3
doesn't isn't me so you don't have to
take it but this is getting scary
this is getting very easy here look at
the time situation six seconds for Teddy
now h f3 go gosh Queen is just anchor
black kind of knows no draw there oh my
goodness what incredible resourcefulness
by let me get you into Queen o FG oh my
check but it doesn't help no it doesn't
and this is an extra Queen there Wow Wow
you know Teddy had that one it felt like
it just slipped through his fingers it
did it absolutely did Queen e1 there I
moved that he should see I just think he
consistently underestimated the danger
and kudos to levy with seconds on his
clock one resource after another
extending the game and pounced when he
had the opportunity
yeah honestly from that early position
where the levees pieces had no room to
breathe and then he got that tremendous
attack you have to give him credit for
fighting tooth and nail and at long last
he was able to break through so levy
played a fantastic fight there his
position the Oh
it'll need some work and Teddy will
definitely be upset with these first two
games when at the end of Game one he
missed an opportunity to win and I saw
him shake his head at some point so I
think he realized that he missed the win
and then in game two there he just had a
stranglehold on the position and he let
Levy escape and not just escape but get
a full point and rook g1 going for g4
how do you feel about this decision in
the five minute portion of the match
I actually I've experimented with this
line myself with white I you know it's
it's a fairly theoretical line I mean
this g4 idea recurs in many of these
positions it's been championed by
players like mama D ro and Joe baba very
dynamic players and it's it's not as
unsound as it seems and whites just look
at White's development look at those
bishops whites develop virtually all of
his pieces the King can Castle queenside
so it's a very double-edged position
White's weakening his position a lot but
he's also going for the throat and
Levy's going for the positions that he's
comfortable in and he knows Teddy will
not feel himself and so I think this is
a very good practical decision
maybe g5 instead of 94 was to be
considered but who knows I don't know if
they're still in theory or not so what's
going on here the night goes to d5 you
can't play E for for white so from d5
you play E for my naked sent to f4
that's not a good look for you and the
Queen would love to join up with the
bishop on a1 and they you know Fisher
bait one queen bee - but you to get the
rook out of the way first and in the
meantime black and get some moves with
Bishop e7 Pawnee v levy plays Bishop d3
going after the h7 pawn and I'm not
exactly a I'm not convinced that g6 it's
not just a fine move here it looks scary
look at that open diagonal h4 h5 comes
into mind that's what he does it's a
little bit slow though bit should be 797
could keep things well protected
Teddy's just gonna watch a couple of
important points here not to allow the
queen of c3 not to allow a bishops a
Conchie six if he manages to keep that
under control positionally speaking you
know his situation is his positions
fairly solid
although Bishop b7h frog does scare me
and I'm not even playing but that looks
very risky because I know I have some
discoveries against this and I don't
have three but in general allowing h5
cracking the sort of theme kettle pawn
structure it is worrisome it is even
with the knight on e7 I agree you don't
want to open the H file
opening the F file weakens the e6 fund
so Teddy once again with problems to
solve here and he's got to act very
concretely he can't just slink away and
you know hope that everything's gonna be
protected this is a critical moment in
this game and another big issue is Queen
c7 age 595 hoping to clog the dragon
with your bishop after 95 Bishop e5 some
of these positions will just lose the c5
pawn so even if you end up removing the
threat along the long diagonal your c5
pawn is a backwards pawn that's actually
quite easy to attack good point
and notice levy keeping his King in the
center for the time being he's not
necessarily in a hurry to Castle long
but as you pointed out Robert wet if and
when you do Castle long c4 is gonna be a
lot harder to execute because of wide
stranglehold on that square Teddy going
for rookie my guess is he wants to
follow up with Knight h8 against age 5
but what about H takes G 6 in this
position so a knight of a plane and h6
g6 is tempting I don't like that at all
look at a book with a knight on g6 this
looks very sketchy from I mean this has
to be great for white or 95 and 94 know
that that would hurt if you get them
Knight to e4 what you really want is a
go Knight f3 to g4 it and just check me
just King on the dark squares look at
the Megaton g4
threads Knight h6 with check and mate
but you can't get there because the h2
square is covered with Michelin d6 but
it's one of these positions where I'm
always looking to get my night either
efore g4 and just go for those softened
dark squares yeah I mean I'm the more I
look at this to less down sides I see it
as simply taking on c5 and he does not
only is this upon a free one but you
can't take on c5 because then that Queen
June appear on c5 and then on d4 but if
you don't take on c5 that night as you
said Robert can appear on e4 this is
this just looks miserable for Teddy and
again I think he's chosen a slightly too
passive of a solution to these tactical
problems he has indeed and 94 is coming
next you called it is it's gonna happen
in there's nothing that black can do
about it because capturing on well can I
can I try Knight e3 de 3 Bishop c5 and
then trying to take your Bishop on d3
but you have before that should be Loras
nasty hitting this rook on a mission
when c5 so under attack that's just that
or even
see 525 there that that diagonal I mean
it's just such a long term weakness and
it's so hard to resolve as long as you
don't put something on that long
diagonal you can test it it's just every
long-term advantages in whites favor
every short-term advantages in whites
favor this is misery absolute misery for
for Teddy here and he's trying to find a
way out and there doesn't seem to be one
so I tend not to recommend resigning in
this format it's too early to be
thinking about the long run but levy is
the favorite in the bullet portion and
we've already seen Teddy in mutual time
trouble a collapse in the first two
games so I think that he could consider
resigning just to get more five-minute
games available to him yeah I mean
that's and you my mean first alone I'd
be 7 as possible and then take T 695 in
your ID of 94 I mean that's why can even
ignore any threats on his Queen because
Knight h6 will be checkmate so that
looks like it hurts
lemme kind of sure is just savoring its
position and to your point Robert I do
think it's it's kind of sensible because
you don't want to get into the habit of
dragging things out constantly
especially when you basically know that
there's very very limited chances to
save the game I think Teddy should bank
on the five-minute portion to make a
statement and and you know he needs to
make these adjustments quickly for the
rest of this portion and definitely for
the for the bullet and the blood and the
and the three-minute portion he just he
has to play more actively he has to take
more risks at least in my opinion he
does indeed and right now levies
thinking so what is he thinking about it
just seems like a position with your
spoiled for choice he goes for the 97
line and Queen b6 you just have to do
something like that it's a sad necessity
and ok Queen c7 still might 66 the Queen
on c2 is protected so I would just take
on d6 and then go forward with the 95 94
plan but don't it what I was going to
say is this is one of those positions
what if somehow black survives and next
few moves like you might not be losing
anymore you know if you can get a quick
rook c8 Bishop b5 and try to get some
counter play it's one of those positions
where it's somehow you may miraculously
sort
if I'd played to kick the Queen out but
you know is it not gonna go to G for VH
- what's the exact plan here maybe it
could be - Queen B - Bishop h8 no that's
one thing that comes to mind that
definitely would not take the Queen here
just I would play queen bee - he's
that's the calculate Knights hc3 that
was an idea that came up earlier and
that's kind of to your point Robert that
he does I don't like that decision I
mean obviously he's still winning here
there's no doubt about that
but I thought he had to go for the
throat actually I mean I'm not sure this
is so easy anymore Knight comes to d7
exactly then black can get City v e4 if
I push your Bishop out the way so this
is one of those positions where levy is
still doing great
he's been out playing Teddy from the
very start but now we're in a position
that went from what looked like totally
winning to looking like hey you you're
winning
likely but you really have to be
accurate here because a couple pieces
get traded and the rooks get active for
for black then there's counter play so
the knight on d5 doing a great job of
covering the c7 squared so there's no
room c7 ideas and black tryna get a
five-minute Oh Robert you've put your
Nostradamus hat on in the morning and it
and it hasn't come off yet
I mean you've called so many things in
the morning match and now this where I
was sure the game would end without
three moves but now it's it's a dogfight
once again and rookie six comes in that
Bishop on g6 and some trouble as well
this is going where is it going cuz
Bishop c5 there's rook to c6 I think and
the bishop is simply trapped
I mean I'm shocked this is really
turning around very quickly and this is
one of the most frustrating things that
can happen - it's having to be so many
times not just in blitz or both in
classical chess as well where you get a
winning position you know you're winning
I have a good example of that in the
Isle of Man I was playing caster pure
and I'm winning for so many moves I know
I'm winning and then keep on making
mistakes
my opponent keeps hearing they're
fighting back and then lo and behold if
he makes a draw and I'm just so angry at
myself for letting it go and which of
the many moves here for black would you
play he goes rooks is he just gonna
trade from 80-85 was to be considered
but now that push funny five it's it's
weirdly ensconced on that square it's
not easy to get to what about trading on
c1 playing for FC 6500 that's right
it's like a
fish you know jumping from one area to
the other still the rook c5 very
interesting he's try the bank on the
activity of his pieces but what is his
idea after takes takes Bishop c4 so he's
gonna trade on c5 Bishop c4 and then
there's efore in the rook to e5 the g5
lawn is one bet has gone a little far
and I'm gonna rope x-rays the bishop it
does five will come out from the bishop
me Bishop da it's some moment soon and
take on d5 with Bishop da get that
Bishop six but there are two knights and
isn't c5 Knight can go to d3 if you ever
take me on d5 so that's something that
you have to look out for the be for fun
is not hanging here precisely because of
that there should be five Bishop e5
Bishop before there's ninety three check
not to mention that opposite colored
bishops the president makes you worry
like am i blowing this game in 28
seconds dunya there's not a lot of time
here for levy nope and there's still a
whole lot of tactics to sort through not
a lot of time for Teddy either and you
know we've seen him take long things and
oh that was a big mistake I think 93
check Intermezzo would have been much
stronger unless I missing something
I think you were right but here Teddy's
gonna try to hope deal rooks do six and
eight five a four maybe oh my god well
here's Bishop c3 so there's always a way
out here
rookie four to rock age four I would do
that right now throw this rook on a
chore there he goes g3 though no
vertebral cage for you can't take my
goodness unbelievable that's a beautiful
resource actually you can white do
anything here if I go put my Brooklyn h4
you're stuck completely stuck reach for
it he's got to go King f1 but and then
there's a drama it's one rook each one
check wrench officials I'm sure he's a
Dracula
wait what do you do oh my goodness oh my
gosh oh my god bishop away and there was
no need for that there was oh my god
oh he worked his way out of it he just
hung a bishop and that happens you
forget you have a certain mechanism that
works in one position and you forget
that the position has changed I know
we're gonna pull up the analysis board
here just to show that one more time
because there was an immediate raw
available to Teddy as you said he was
relying on the fact that when the King
on a1 you can't take the Bishop rook h1
is checkmate
but after King f1 there was rook each
one forcing group to g1 and many moves
holder George's rook anywhere back is a
drove Bishop e2 check for King G to
Bishop f3 check back and the King needs
to stay attached to the work
she was a draw by force by repetition
there so miss chance there by Teddy in a
position that was very clarified and he
was the one with plenty of time these
mistakes happened he's going to need to
calm down
rebound and look at Levy he's taking it
to Teddy right now by playing this
variation if we scroll back a few moves
here with Bishop before Queen C Jun Enzo
and then d5 and C father used to play
this is black it's a very sharp line
with chances for both we can definitely
see that levy put in quite a bit quite a
bit of effort preparing for this match
he's getting very sharp positions now
levees got to work on his execution once
again gets that advantage but his
ability to survive in queue time
pressure I mean that's reaping some
rewards and this has just got to be so
incredibly frustrating for Teddy I mean
one big chance after another and at the
critical moment you know there's either
a blunder or doesn't quite find the
right execution so how does Teddy come
back from this what do you think's going
through his mind right now well right
now he's got a position where he's two
bishops he's up eight pawns opponent c5
not the best pawn in the world but it is
an extra pawn and if you let live too
long you can be in some trouble and this
reminds me of the u.s. women's chess
champ to playoff between Nagi Pike Izzy
in any way because anyone a game from
the white side of this position in their
playoff and it's very difficult for
black as I said I have experience
playing this from the black side where
you are down upon and you've given up
the two bishops so if the position opens
up that favor is the bishop pair and
look right now this night on you a
bishop on c8 it just doesn't feel like
the type of position anyone really
enjoys from the black side and there are
some concrete things that you should
know
in his variation but it feels like levee
spending the time here not so familiar
shall we say Teddy manage to ward off
the initiative boy here we go I mean for
a long evening RNA hey let me just write
it right down 8:40 p.m. Eastern first
punt of the day that's actually not bad
because usually it happens when I switch
it off Alexa Alexa's alarm in the
morning so I'm making some progress and
the exact type of position that I was
referring to by the way Diane I'm not
ignoring your puns I appreciate you no
no no please do ignore them it'll help
no I want you to Chronicle Chronicle
your best moments and from my point of
view your worst moments but thank you
for doing that
and speaking of worst moments look at
this bishop on c3 this King went to h8 I
mean the position is clearly good for
what you have an extra pawn still queen
III is a move that you can consider
giving up the g2 ponts you Castle
queenside and go after that King friends
its Queen III Queens you to Castle long
here come virtue one and I don't think
your g7 square is gonna be very happy
it's not and the only thing I would say
is you know Teddy's gotta be remembering
those previous games or he had
overwhelming positions he's got to put
them out of his mind in this case I like
the move Queen I don't think it's a bad
move but maybe you can we take SEF 3 and
then he 5 I mean was it strictly
necessary to trade Queens the advantage
is still absolutely overwhelming in the
endgame so in this specific instance
maybe simplification is not a bad idea
yes and quit after you actually think
might be the best of even better than
Queen III because quit III offered black
pepper treat it just temporarily hurt
your pawn structure but giving you an
isolated pawn now if you capture an f3
in comes my Bishop there and that's
going to be very nice and now II five
can I just take the pawn you know Jacob
or take the pawn yeah give me your pawn
on e5 you take on c5 at Bishop d6
hitting your rook on f8 and you're 95
and if you try a rook e8 move in between
I go Bishop d4 I could drop my bishop
back to e3 as is needed to close the
e-file from your rook and I'm just gonna
castle and say I'm at least up one pawn
him maybe even stay up - yeah and that's
exactly what he does his time management
quite good as well he's got plenty of
time to convert here now wherever
there's a knight there's some trouble
he's got to watch those squares like
beat the b3 square those bishops are a
little bit loose but as you said if he
can castle if he can consolidate chase
away that night I mean at least up upon
all of the positional advantages I mean
this is this is looking very very rosy
for Teddy here and I think the best
black can do is some kind of Bishop move
that's officially ecigs rook CH I get to
the c5 pawn but you're taking one of the
two extra pawns probably not quite good
enough and here's Bishop before y could
actually thing about playing f3 just
King f2 because if I take your knight on
with me for my c5 pawn feels a lot
better and actually if I go f3 where's
your knight
going to probably g5 into e6 is a sad
necessity from last review and castling
queenside is the one trick that you
should avoid because then there's an
discovery with night up to and even now
let's say you give what a free move and
we play to see a capsule queenside runs
Eaton Knight takes f2 still because the
money too is hanging at the back
and now maybe before I wouldn't give
this fun up for no reason
before Knight c3 is nothing to fear you
can just sidestep it with Bishop f3 I
don't see a downside to before I feel
like that on phalanx on the Queen side
is it's going to be huge that pawn
family is actually often worth in
exchange where even if I lose a rook
when I get a minor piece here just get
those pawns rolling in here Bishop f3
what's what's blacks response obituary
to some kind Bishop d3 player your b7
cause maybe Bishop before and but
there's just no way that can work I mean
Bishop f3 Bishop before and then white
just needs some it may be Bishop takes
e4 and King I'm even thinking of King d2
there just immediately I like it because
that pawn in f3 is gonna cover the e4
square that's a good move right I'm
taking away this night retreat and then
I'm up there was connected pawns over
there on the Queen side yeah I mean
Teddy doing a good job of time
management here here specifically
there's some tactics so there's every
reason to take your time but again he's
got to put the threshold somewhere he
can't let himself tip to you know thirty
seconds because we know what that could
lead to and there we see Bishop f3 it
looks like he he might just carry this
on home and this is a very critical
position for Teddy because he needs to
win this game for his confidence right
levy has had some these kind of if he
positions in some moments he was
completely winning in Game three before
Bochy and said he knew he was having a
draw and then when you failed to convert
that draw you just feel like nothing's
going right for me so if you're able to
win a game you get that taste of victory
then you feel more confident your
chances in for levy side of things if
you can hold this game you're like I can
hold anything I am they already up two
points in the match and I should lose
this game three and about two pawns
right now but hey the game's not over
until somebody either designs or
checkmates on the board so very good
expression I think I might write that
down it's my collection of uh 845
take note of what time it is 8:45 and
that's a round time - I think you timed
it perfectly and the problem is this
knight on c3 it's actually kind of
stranded and you pointed this out robber
this pawn on f3 once again you might
look at those bonds it's a terrible pawn
structure what is steady doing but then
that pond star is the very important
purpose of defending me Foursquare and
in this situation what is up this much
material that's so much more valuable
than whatever sorts of double bonds
Teddy may have and Bishop d4 here just
trying to offer a trade of rooks maybe
Bishop d2 is a little smarter and that
opt for this is like e - perhaps
and you could repeat the position with
Bishop back to e3
as is needed but yeah somehow this just
feels like it should be easy but then
this Knight is a tricky piece and you
can't so easily win this game true maybe
takes 106 and rook you want that rap
lately circumscribed yeah nice rook e1
next and as you were about to say the
knight is completely stuck over there
and so why not just trade off all the
rooks and they run your King / - its
acting Knight
yeah that's one of the most tilting
situations out there then that night on
a 4 bishop on g4 where the night
literally has no squares it's you know
total helplessness and you know after
the rook trade teddy can just saunter
over to b3 and snap off that night and
that'll be that that's the dream that is
stuck over there and there's a
resignation and you know for some of you
may say wait there's still pieces on the
board why would you resign it's because
that night was trapped with what was
already up to pawns and Levy recognizing
that hey this wasn't my game so I mean
from match perspective there's still 31
plus minutes remaining almost 13 minutes
so it's not like he he can waste so much
time so I think for levy you know what
he needs to do is just play just like he
did the last time hit white but don't
let Teddy out right don't let him off
the hook for getting a sketchy position
of the opening definitely I think levy
is displaying very good opening
preparation but he's playing a little
bit too fast
once that preparation is complete I
think he's he's miss handling some of
these initiatives as you said so the
adjustment he should I think make here
is just to tell himself to be a little
bit slower once he's out of prep because
you know he's getting a lot of very
promising positions from Fratelli
that one must feel very very good even
though
he's still clearly disappointed you know
he's the moral effect of that victories
is obviously huge it is and Teddy
playing a semi torus which I also have
never seen him played before so
something's going on I'm gonna have to
ask Teddy what he was looking at in
anticipation of this match
but clearly putting an effort in the
opening stages but right now this is
what happens when you're not so familiar
with the position because he spent what
was that 23 seconds well let me spend 23
seconds and then Teddy returned the
favor of us only 23 seconds of his own
and now we're in a position that to our
eyes looks like yeah we've seen things
like this all the time but if you are
not someone plays these positions
regularly you're just like what is the
exact plan here does white play for
efore or do I leave the pot on III to
keep my pawn chain more solid in the
center it is e4 can that backfire with
some kind of d6 Bishop e7 are we getting
a sort of groom felled like structure
and the answer is yes but the bishop on
e7 rather than on g7 so here's e4 and I
would probably take and play b6 here but
is there anything else that black can do
yeah I mean he's got to somehow find
find beautiful desk ways to apply
pressure on the center and white of
course can levy rich his strong pawn
Center 848 number 2 8:14 later you go
you go in timeout exactly you should not
be waving that's that was taking a walk
through downtown Charlotte I need to
refresh myself that was so bad I was a
sheriff so bad what isn't bad I think
though is maybe b6 Bishop e7 there's
this cross between
grünfeld and Senate Aras and black just
needs to get his pieces onto positions
where they can pressure White's Center I
still think Libby's got the edge here
though yeah what should be better the
thing that happens in these positions is
you you look at it let's let's take a
holistic view here the d4 and e4 pawns
two central pawns for white only one for
black on e6 white now he has an extra
Center pawn but more space with those
pawns on d4 and e4 but then you start
thinking endgame having outside pawns
can be a really good thing for black
because when there's an endgame you
don't have a queen just to run from side
to side on the board
that you should draw
attention to that pawn and if it's on
the side of the board then your opponent
can start hitting you the center while
your pieces are distracted so this is a
long-term idea in such a position but
Teddy's really spending a lot of time
here and now he finally plays b6 but
that's a common idea that you need to be
able to play instantly you cannot spend
a minute on that move after spending 31
seconds on seat 64 it's just too much
time and you know let me we'll go into
the think tank at some point but I'm not
sure I trust Teddy right now if he's
going to be down in that block
definitely we just saw make the mckayla
maroney not impressed facial twitch and
I think he's you know he's he's lower on
time he's slightly worse but as you said
Robert there's a lot of classical games
played long ago where what the white
player doesn't necessarily understand
that all of these P straights favor
black as you said upon endgame is
oftentimes just completely winning for
black because of the possibility of
creating an outside passer and and using
this this very classical plan of
distracting the king and walking your
own King around to just mop up all those
pots indeed and Bishop f4 played by levy
saying I'm gonna kind of try to go d5
and d6 at some moment but that's also
risky you give yourself an isolated pawn
if you play d5 I'm happy to take it and
he does it I'm happy to take it and then
move my knight actually where does the
knight belong this was I'm Michael
Knight b4 yup and d6 Bishop f6 that
runaway train can really backfire it
gets very sharp though night before
plate I don't see an alternative to d6 I
think as the Russian expression goes
having said a you have to say B but
Robert then that a2 font could be
potentially taken because that knight
can return to c3 yes it can that's a
Knight d5 should do the position just as
well rook be 195 when hitting your
bitch'll on a 4th and running Knight c3
so two options here for Teddy let's say
you know you said of runaway train never
look back but I think you're gonna look
back on that move and say I wish I
didn't push that bone so far yup it's a
it's something you do you ride the rush
of you know I'm attacking all these
pieces threat threat threat but you know
your opponent evades the threats and
what's left behind is is not always to
your liking and levies got
thanks to patch together here maybe
Bishop e5 should be considered but then
Bishop takes f3 that doesn't work which
if f6 there's Bishop b2 nice variation
there you end up up a piece or do you
because Bishop d8 there should be one
Bishop e7 I mean it's that deep on is
close but you're right this way for and
you block the palms progress you've not
within three seven and you can move your
knight X exactly I'm not giving you my
knight I'm just gonna nod about
somewhere and then win that pawn back on
d7 yeah I mean this is and and I think
rooks out of the two rook moves rook c1
is probably better because Ruby one
walks into those potential Forks so but
I'm not sure I mean it's it's hard to
Singh the lesser evil among many
undesirable options that's exactly what
levy has to do here he plays a very
interesting move Queen d2 secondly
exchange he's giving up the exchange on
a one and out of necessity rather than
desired
do you play 95 here first or do you take
that rook on anyone I like the thought
of 95 because Bishop a1 he's definitely
gonna take the bishop yeah
85 played now it's probably also quite
good and definitely not enough
compensation rook comes out to the open
file pawn on d6 is annoying but it just
doesn't constitute enough initiative for
that exchange and the run b7 is an
excellent piece and I can still come to
c3 with the rook protecting on C it's a
rook d1 is meant by Knight c3 so you
can't actually reinforced up on anymore
and 95 will take your pawn on d6 because
usually you have some good discovery
when a queen walks in the line of a
bishop but here there's nothing of note
so I will gladly steal your pawn and
live to tell the tale so Knight d4
played and F 5 F for something I want to
have haven't been 96 so I can't push my
up on just yet but I'm looking at ways
to close that Bishop off from the
defense the d6 pawn
yeah and Queen f6 should be considered
here as well neck's is bringing left 4 -
yup I I thought about that too I'm just
a little concerned about knife knife f5
as one prominent Grandmaster likes to
refer to that square I think Teddy is
definitely supposed for choice Queen f6
Knight c3 concretely they all should be
pretty good moves I like your queen up
six we were just freezing that night in
its place for the time being because the
rook on a1 is under attack
behind it so queen of six covers
five squared negative five is really
annoying and that's why it's called
knife f5 as you're using a little
feingold ism just do a show because the
nine at five goes to e seven with a
check it forks the king and the rook so
here's 93 and night at five
what is Teddy's plan responsible yeah I
I mean I was sure there was something
but I wasn't able to find anything
completely satisfactory for instance if
you take on e2 and go cleanups well
that's a movie right now because Levy
doesn't do it this looks okay
ninety-four play just trying to trade
pieces you want to take that one G
through for sure so Levy gonna take on
e4 and I was thinking yes I'm kind of
queen F for Queen III but yes this
should be of course good for black but
it's not over the rope might land on e7
I would even take the time to play h3 or
h4 for white that would I mean because
with the back rank being as exposed as
it is all of these tactics basically
fail but maybe now Knight f5 I'm not
sure about the shoveit
what exactly is Teddy planning against
Anna 5s we're about to see we've rook c5
perhaps just to try to kick that night
while stopping 97 check with the full
force them and from c5 eventually I
would love to get my birth to d5 and
there he goes risky fine there it is 97
King h8 and they've got a d7 like I'm
getting my pawn to the seventh rank like
97 check can you j d7 what's blacks move
there exactly that Bishop on g3 covering
c7 there should be 5 employed by levy um
what does he want on f6 here I know f6
looks very shaky indeed but maybe 97
check there you might have whole roof d5
twin h6 by the way it's funny because I
was going to say that and I'm glad you
did I was going to say Queen e6 is a
nasty threat that is just a freakishly
strong move because let's say I put a 6
Queen age 6 GH 6 96 is check and mate to
this poor King within configuration let
me almost have something like this in
the previous game and so we have our
minds on a knight h6 checkmate idea and
f6 finally played by Teddy a good move
probably a necessary move which also
frees up the f7 Square for the rook if
you want to come some drink that way I
don't be a 97 has to be play though
otherwise that
I would have been hanging on a five now
Bishop g3 I think is the most prudent
yeah anywhere else is from Chi five
right oh yeah there it is and again I
contend that I think h3 has to be played
because that frees up potentially the
rook from you one I just don't see
long-term compensation though for levy
Teddy should be able to win if he's
careful but there's always tricks
connected with that night ninety-seven
certainly do not count might be out
we've seen him display incredible
resourcefulness even with such a cute I
pressure and what's blacks move in this
position I'm not finding easy moves by
crook t8 seems to be you know common
sense move just trying to get after this
pawn it steady eventually gonna have to
go rook g5 and sack the rub for the
bishop to get the d6 bar well not so
fast for age for mmm-hmm and now he's
killing two birds with one stone he's
grabbing space on the Queen side maybe
okay queen b5 that's very very risky he
needs to give Queen to like the diagonal
to try to check me he goes coin c4 here
look at steady cook that's why I'm I'm
so worried about both of their positions
right now I don't know who's better and
you know watch out we not so good Queen
f7 you're saying it's e3 26 okay 22 how
do you do this
Queen d4 slow and stead Knight applies
there was a knife Robert Knight a5
Queenie a might have been winning that
was actually really nasty will show that
off the game he's actually making it
black is now the one who is pushing
these pawns he could be six it's about
time okay for a six-night you say oh
don't you six what a tactic King h7 you
have to play awesome moment he's gonna
lose on time and this is 0.1 seconds oh
my gosh this game really dangerous so he
stops Eddy now down a two second oh my
gosh of g7 wins another piece this
collapses time scrambles Teddy just is
not able to keep up with leve
levies been very impressive in the time
scrambles he has I mean with by the
narrowest of threads with one second on
his clock he keeps the game going and
now some stale matrix maybe but I'm
looking that to some kind of stalemate
but it'll rock isn't close to white
state t26 take what he said to the free
polls that was a free base and now rope
c7 okay or denied FA checkmate also does
the trick
that's beautiful checkmate
and I mean in these time crunches teddy
was one who had more time had an extra
exchange but that pawn on d6 having upon
the sixth rank is often worth some kind
of material sacrifice because it's
always angling to push forward and try
to promote so a tough loss there by
Teddy and me just wow wow wow wow yeah
why was the good word to describe this
we've seen this up and time and time
again and you know once YB stock that
exchange he developed these long-term
threats and you kind of called it Robert
I just feel like black hats add more
convincingly earlier but just who what a
finale where we're seeing so many of
these time scrambles and
and levius is the one with the nerves of
steel he is indeed and that was a theme
in the match against Danny wrench
because we got the bullet Danny was able
to score +4 before the tiebreaker when
Teddy actually scored +2 in return but
right now Teddy needs to calm down he's
playing quite well right I don't think
we are criticizing either player's
quality of play for the most part leve
miss you know he wouldn't push too deep
on he regret it but he was able to come
up with nice just activity throughout
the entire game and now Teddy with the
white pieces once has to watch out for
efore after the movie found a knight g4
in 94 right so I'm gonna think seems a
little bit off about said his opening
play here Knight g4 is a good idea de
also possible by the way I have a hard
time believing white can capture on e5
there again d 95 that looks weird but as
you're saying for Knight takes d4 and
rook could be one simply maybe maybe
what white gets away with that I
wouldn't risk it honestly I think 94
Knight ft7 is is a safer option and
levies in a position where you know he
can you can afford to play with an
abundance of caution he but he decides
to take any five very interesting he
does and well ephors a big threat so
you're gonna have to avoid that he takes
it yeah it felt like he had to if he 4
was about to be played that would give
black a tremendous open diagonal for
Bishop and I think Lenny can't believe
that punk could be captured you know
it's like one of those moves like
there's no way you can take on e5 and
survive this but as you're suggesting
there's no good night discovery yeah I
mean very often the King's Indian
I just felt like I I said that yeah in a
very far beyond a car one and so and I
have to give a shout out to love you
either way who has the best 5b on a car
one impression and I have heard Bobby I
was probably watching by the way he was
messaging me right before the show
saying he loves this for many things the
matches have been very exciting Fabiana
fabbi of course an amazing player what
an honor that we have some incredible
grandmasters watching 9 ft 7 but I was
gonna say it in a King's Indian you
usually have some sort of discovery now
this gets complicated though Knight 67
is their Bishop takes c3 and that night
on a fade might get stranded yup the
knight gifts tonight f8 Bishop a1 and
the knight is not getting out is it but
there's some kind of Bishop a3 you're
attacking your Bishop protecting my
knight at Bishop g7 Bishop takes g6 like
I don't know something like this is
getting tricky at the very least it is
problems to solve here for for Teddy I
mean not only is this getting tricky
might just be losing a piece here I mean
it because f4 is definitely something
you don't want to play Knight takes e5
and that's just an eyesore Bishop e5 and
then Queen h4 just might knock white out
there yeah I'm with you there that just
looks absolutely abysmal Queen h4 the
bishops aiming at the White King side
and they're no pieces over there to
protect so you have to take on d7 yeah I
think it doesn't look good but they're
worse things in the world of being down
a piece for two and Max three pawns I
don't think there are Robert that is the
worst thing the worst fate sometimes it
feels that way
I must admit yeah I mean these sometimes
you know it's it's one of the most
frustrating feelings when you when
you're looking at a position and you
can't believe that that you don't have a
defensive resource but the longer you
look at it do with comport you realize
you just don't sometimes chess works in
weird ways and sometimes all of the
positional factors can just be
misleading and in basketball they say
good often speaks good defense well in
chess oftentimes tactical properties
speed positional considerations yes that
is true
as long as you're not going off just for
the tactics you're absolutely right then
you know you can cat find a nice counter
blow at the right moment and well
here is a situation where both players
know that there's something in this
position for black but they don't know
exactly what they're putting on their
thinking caps levy here looking very
studious and he's just trying to figure
out
it should take C 3 that looks like it's
something because what else is black
doing is there kind of Queen tasty 7 as
well like I just take on d7 Bishop b2
play rook to d8 probably not I just drop
my Bishop anywhere and I'm trading
Queens because the rook on D it has no
protector so he takes the seat three
take on that fate and taking on a 1-week
anticipate this and I think Bishop e3 is
the best move well I just think he asked
himself for what would I be do and uh
well he he managed to find find to find
a particular resource and now he's just
playing some timid Queen h4 in this
position but yeah I mean Queen h4
because King h7 of course Bishop g6
that's a devilish trick bye-bye mr.
Coleman there but that night on h7 just
went from the frying pan into the fire
and yes Queen h4 is a good move what
about Bishop e2 as a response and take
on h7 let's the Kingdom Bishop f3 just
trying to say you're Queen side has not
developed here your pawn on f7 can
become a target so I don't think that
Libby's quite out of the woods despite
the fact that we both like egos night a6
what a calm move but is it good well
that's a very zen just take a deep
breath you know inhale through exhale
through one nostril kind of move but I'd
be a little bit nervous about playing it
I don't see her I don't I don't see I
don't see how you do back to it that
night have a bishop takes g6 is a
possibility and trading Queens and
giving your neck to g5 squared you're
saying I've got my third pawn for the
piece Bishop Bishop where Bishop g6 here
aha and then you want to get it through
g5 but my issue with that would be
Bishop g6 F G so you take the Queen and
go Knight g5 yep yeah I mean it's just
to me it seems like Bishop f6 there and
the night before I just feel like blacks
still piling on in the endgame but maybe
that's the best I can do
I agree with you of course it's looking
good for black but at certain point you
have to make a decision because you
can't be down a piece and down a minute
on the clock when you don't have full
compensation for safety so f4 is another
idea if the King takes a Chapman
f5 I would really look at that as well
but after f4 there could even be some
kinda c5 might be forward type of thing
trading off and he plays
for it doesn't last but 95 going after
the bishop on d3 feels quite strong it
does and that bishop on a1 is quite
comfortable 95 is a very strong move
counter-attack in the bishop on d3 the
Queen trade is squarely and in blacks
favor here I'm this maybe Bishop takes
g6 now is the best that I can do but
then Airport was not a useful move right
exactly exactly it's like you want to
put the pawn back on f2 if you're gonna
go but she gets g6 it's sad maybe Bishop
a3 here I was thinking about that but
Bishop me that worry in d3 Bishop c5 oh
no what am i doing no no that doesn't
work
yeah there's no not enough Tempe there
he does it but Queen d3 Queen a1
probably he wants but then Queen takes
c3 check finally pick off the night
that's just completely waiting for black
yeah I'm worried about this Bishop on b7
as well because my king s go to h1 I'm
looking at the g2 Square and
anticipating some kind of check mean I
think all things considered perhaps this
is the best complicated line that Teddy
can come up with but ultimately it
should just be very very good here for
levy this was just a very well
calculated game
bye-bye levy I mean he he went for the
principle line he he didn't shy away
from you know a move that might have
appeared to be dubious at the start Oh
Knight 63 probably still good because he
can always support the night with Bishop
before that's the downside of Teddy's
move f4 true you'd love to your f4 to f3
as a move just to take away the e4
square from Bishop b4 because white
wants like Queen c3 it should be 2 and
go for a checkmate hope I drew the wrong
diagonal I'm gonna try to draw the right
one this time there it is the dark
squares but if the bishops on e4 and the
night stays on d3 you can't configure
your Bishop and queen in a way that
allows you to deliver that kind of
checkmate yeah good point I mean how
many funds does white have for the piece
only well two pawns for the pieces is
not necessarily that bad it's it's as
you point out it's the presence of all
these positional weaknesses on top of
that that really makes White's position
so yeah basically untenable also the
time situation not doing any favorites
to teddy either no it's not but rookie
ones a good move of course
pinning the 90th Bishop b4 is ideas
Queen c3 and
quick Bishop b2 or the Knights pin but I
don't think you have time to accomplish
this but he's gonna try and the only
other idea was to play f5 from white
instead of rook to d1 B ends up choosing
this line and Bishop e2 now is a threat
aha I considered briefly Queen h4 but I
can actually try to get away with the
rook takes c3 in that position although
if you take everything on g3 and like
Queen e1 I mean that's actually not
entirely clear cut so levy has I think
one more accurate move to find here that
line looks very good to my eye for black
it actually also simplifies things
although yeah that's true just take e3 I
forgot about that
mm-hmm but Queen h4 I have two Queen h4
I'll go rook d3 Bishop e3 no I can't
ruin g3 like lots of maybe I can can you
Queen da and then Bishop b2 I'm trying
to acquit checkmate you but you have f6
yeah it's actually a very good thought
but Fitz f6 is actually very annoying
and I'm here I was I don't equate or as
an easy move Knight f4 maybe Wow
wait no knife riders trick take your
queen yeah but 92 yeah but then you're
working it oh you're gonna protect you
offended you oh yeah if you went with
the wrong order oh he would daddy with
all the different order here look at
Teddy 3 Bishop e2 sure he too was so
savvy there so he made it I had the idea
I just put in the right move order and
now we take on d3 this is looks like
it's Teddy's game all of a sudden Wow
maybe he had to go night afore I was
just trying to be fancy but look at this
look at this turn of events do you play
a 45 and Teddy does you just dude this
is his game to win he's got to play for
a winner here he can't just satisfy
himself with the draw no he cannot if f5
whenever that King Queen moves if she's
me from east 6 you would apply e6
yourself so instead let me take some
that dish 25 is worth it one second on
the clock as well once again h4 now h5
oh my gosh Zhi Jing Zhi Zhu no don't let
Queen f2 are you stage 3b NH 5 coming in
this can be very hard it's me it's me oh
my god my gosh me oh my gosh h5 still
still mating open we need to very good
move oh my gosh we have 5 Oh take on g6
and put Queen d7 King age 6
King GA no maid
5 H 5 o Queen trade but this is still
good for white right it is they'll put
those pawns and c7 is now hanging so you
protects it and now how do you make this
work he's moving his Queen side pawns
which somehow you needed to get g5
working this is no longer clear-cut no
it's not I don't levees gotta gain some
time though have firewood I was gonna
move this / I'm driving a wedge in with
g5 this is here comes u v g6 Wow f6 just
go up six yes very important to don't
trade those pawns off because then they
wouldn't be given up and now the route
cannot be given up and good f7 check you
have to take it you have the one pawn
remaining and holy cow that game was
absolutely insane and honestly that was
a flip of the script from what we'd seen
earlier in the match where it looked
like Teddy of some good positions and
Levy thought he clawed back this time
Teddy had a lost position and somehow
the taxes went in his favour and all of
a sudden frustration for Lenny ruspin
and we get back to this triangle
structure here in the semi slob
I'm not used to seeing this from Teddy
he's going for it and dunya
now that levees only up one point this
may be and probably will be the last
game in the five minute portion I mean
who does the momentum favor at this
point I think it favors Teddy but and we
saw him shake his head after the game
and reminds me of those warrior games i
watch Steph Curry misses four
three-pointers in a row that he hits a
half-court shot he walks away shaking
his head that's a head shake of not if
not of disappointment in the immediacy
but he's kind of saying I finally woken
up it's taken me you know it's taken me
almost an hour but here I finally come
and he's still down a point now for levy
very important to realize the greater
picture she's still up a point if
somebody approached him before the match
and said you're gonna be up three and a
half two and a half you know what he
probably would have taken that and he
has the white pieces to boot so you know
levy of course always very calm always
very composed and I think that's gonna
come in handy in this game and this is
actually not something that you know in
my vague recall of things I've discussed
with Teddy I often just forget most of
them but this one I remember talking
about the Cambridge Springs with him we
just talking about chess and Cambridge
Springs seems interesting so the reason
why black goes for one like this is you
look
in black has two bishops but look how
much more space White has this pawn on
d4 is nice you still have two pawns on
one in White's favor in the center but
if black is able to get move like c5 in
and start trading some pieces then the
bishops can come to life so interesting
opening choice by Teddy I think that
right now you are still looking at the
c5 push any moment now that can happen
and well what's your experience like
with the Cambridge Springs well I
haven't spoken to Teddy by the Cambridge
Springs I have spoken him about the
Cambridge summers I actually really
appreciate that because I thought you
would make a Harvard joke so that works
out perfectly since Hari exactly I was
thinking about which angle to take but
I've you typically right-angled Danya so
thank you Robert I mean I was gonna make
a Yale joke there as well but I don't
have any as responsible as response has
no right angles and I was in Ezra Stiles
College so we can keep this going you
know we can do is I make a Stanford joke
next well I would make a history major
joke except I think there's more than
one history major in the room but I
think you know objectively white should
be slightly better I do play the white
side of the Cambridge Springs the
frustrating thing about this is if you
allow c5 black has these latent
advantages right he as the two bishops
very sound structure and why can very
easily overextend him so if I think
that's what levy is concerning himself
with right now the time is already quite
right for c5 levies got to try to find
an antidote to that so that's oftentimes
kind of the battle you know that
revolves around these types of positions
and levy spending so much time here he's
down he's almost you know half the time
that Teddy has in this game something is
feels off right now and g4 woo Tabasco
sauce dumped on this position right here
g4 going for g5 going for Queen h5
trying to check me this black king over
here there are not many defenders in
front of that King so
Danya I actually like this move g4 did
you know it's objectively not great I
love it but 97 might be the you know the
calm move just to try to get rid of this
don't allow g5 to come with the tempo
maybe it's not necessarily 97 just yet
but it feels like a type of defensive
move yeah I mean we talked about
Cambridge Springs came for summers
laddies going for the Cambridge throat
here she Bishop age seven and
oftentimes that's what you need often
times when you have a space advantage a
natural way to transform it is to start
attacking because White's advantages can
evaporate very very quickly with a move
c5 I like this decision very very
practical chess maybe Teddy should go
ninety-seven here preemptively stopping
the Moochie 597 is a hard move to play
because it's a backward move in a
position you already feel underdeveloped
in your queen side and I just want to
show that line with Bishop h7 check if
black plays a6 you dilly-dally
here comes G 597 Bishop takes h7 check
King h7 Queen h5 check King g8 and Queen
takes f7 you get the point it's a check
and white is scooping up all the pawns
and the 27 is hanging in a line
like this even the bishop we're not
hanging is probably a checkmate
to be had for white so that's why g5 is
such a big threat in the position it's
not just because you kicked the knight
in someone tempo move no no there's a
concrete threat of Bishop takes h7 in
that position so 97 doesn't allow that
Queen to get to h5 because the pollen on
g4 it's one of those positions can I
throw my pawn off the board I'll give
you a free pawn there Teddy goes with 97
yeah I felt like that was a very teddy
move as well and and I'm not trying to
suggest that as that I think actually
97's very strong practical move maybe
not the best but it's very debilitating
when when you're trying to whip up an
attack and your opponent keeps playing
solidly so Levy's also got to be very
very careful here because if he allows
one of these central breaks like e5 or
c5 she's making a lot of weaknesses that
are currently hiding beneath the shell
and beneath the closed nature of the
position so this is gonna get a little
bit spicy a little bit dicey for white
yeah you just sound like Walt Clyde
Frazier they're giving me some rhymes
ition and swishing yeah exactly exactly
and if I played by Teddy as you said you
unleash at the right moment and look at
that pollo g4 just yet it's not under
attack but as soon as I make the move at
night f6 or something of that nature
Down Goes your Jeep
you can't Castle kingside which means
you can't castle at all because you've
already moved your Queen side rook and
you technically you're able to cast that
is a possibility but Castle King said is
not a good idea when you played the move
g2 to g4 in such a position ready duping
and swooping and dishing and swishing on
and all the way 35 there's only one
Clyde Frazier you don't get to go walk
like Frazier on me when we're Chesson
and guessing right now and then I'll go
my green okay right between the eyes
that's Kevin Harlan I don't know what
I'm doing yeah I appreciate it as long
as you don't go Reggie Miller on me
we're good no not a chance
no Reggie Miller to taking on as long as
you don't go Marv Albert on me
don't go yes and around me okay I'll try
to avoid it now night at fate opening
the wants ta tan Bishop d6 Bishop
e6 you've to watch Linden hessin that's
a good one
I'm sorry I love you you're such a you
get that late reaction do you know I was
giving you I was throwing flames at your
flames so watch out for some kind of
Knight d5 Bishop d6 and he doesn't work
right now because like no queening
father check but I the corn my I'm
noticing and Knight d5 type of move to
so if levy plays a move like King F 1
and now it doesn't work at all because
between zone f4
you're getting out of the way of these
discoveries actually I really like the
move Queen at 4 we know for just
chiseling his way into White's position
Knight c5 here maybe in DC rook takes c3
maybe a little bit too adventurous but
oftentimes actually even night you know
95 is a little bit too much but in these
positions you got to act fast all of
these holes and White's position but now
King F 1 but then a bishop might appear
on h3 now that is he 5 that Bishop is
for sure appearing on HD but nice if I
might just take it right 95 d 63 rook g2
and there has to be made queen g4
there's h g5
I think Bishop g5 there because if you
take that rook on c1 might be hanging at
the end of the line I know you're right
because the Queen can't come to f3 to
protect that rook on g2 that's pinned
because the Brooklyn c1
is under threat nice variation there but
he's got to have to step out of his
comfort zone Teddy doesn't naturally
like to make moves like every scene I
have faith but and yeah it's a good move
but proud doesn't lend the knockout blow
just yet rookie three played by I wasn't
saved by Tanya well I would have played
up to three ig6 by Teddy and actually
now 92 what is just try to escape this
one yes and it counts yeah 92 and and
that's I mean 9f8 just a little bit too
slow the good thing for teddy is first
of all design situation second of all
even if levy beats back the first wave
of attack let's say 92 Queen c7 you know
what Ted is gonna be threatening Bishop
d6 and then Bishop h3 all of the
positional advantages are still there
this is incredibly difficult to defend
for levy so this exact would having
Bishop e6 is it threat kicking that rook
off oh there it is officially h3 comes
and not only is it a very good check to
put your opponent in but you also
connect your rook so the second rookie
move rookie 7 rook e8 and black still
has the two bishops 95 bit of
desperation take on e5 with your knight
watch out for some kind of second h7
that's the one thing I'm a little
nervous about is if there's a bishop h7
but there's no rotation to me to follow
up because the fish would see it covers
it and whoa Bishop anywhere e six d7
connect your efficiency for is probably
the best move and seven seconds left for
levy counting down here this looks like
a sense game yeah Coleman for the win
bang I'm like Derrick Coleman we going
back in time here Derrick Coleman now he
got me that does not ring a ring a bell
doesn't ring a Roger bell for me oh you
just went full full rajab Dell on me
what he used to play for the worse I
think that's that's the only reason I
know that name but this is just looking
terrible for levy in two seconds on the
clock we've seen him work absolute magic
with no time the problem here is Bishop
g7 is good in Queen age to the position
basically plays itself for black I would
also considered Bishop h2 just to take
away the g1 Square from the White King
and try to get a bit of age to recheck
and it just one of those moves of your
face Fischer made sure with two seconds
left you don't know what to do
you just frazzles you I like Jon's fun
in the chat
mama there goes that Coleman very funny
mister know the same thing with levy
though right mama there goes that Rosman
so I let me just say I hope John's moves
tomorrow are gonna be better than that
part other ones area lopsided match do
you think there are enough pieces on the
e-file oh look at that little child look
oh he had some mates oh oh there's a
free rook oh my that's just over that's
and teddy ties it wow wow wow wow and
Teddy Coleman you know his back was
against the wall he ends up winning two
straight games to close this five-minute
portion and lovey I think these are the
fewest amount of games we've had in a
five-minute portion just seven it's like
three and a half three and a half and
well we are going to go to our first
break here the match is tied three
minutes up next
don't go anywhere you won't want to miss
these basketball puns ahead
[Music]
as you return to the I am non-gm speech
chess champ ship brought to you by chess
calm
we remind everybody that there are some
prizes at stake but mostly this is for
prize for enjoyment entertainment and
you can donate to add to the prize fund
it goes right to the players so if
you're a fan of Teddy if you're a fan of
levy and of course we have matchups
tomorrow with Lawrence Trent and John
Bartholomew Dan Chris and yep and Greg
shadi
feel free to donate and add to that pot
but Danya so far it's been fun I've been
enjoying today tremendously especially
this first you know 5 minute portion
right now was enthralling and we even
had basketball references to boot we did
and we encourage people to also
participate in today's daily question if
you want to see more of these
fascinating amazingly fought matches
give us some suggestions what other
types of matches could we think up to
make other speed chess championships and
be creative
brainstorm that's how great ideas begin
I've been thinking about this all day
long
don't be shy jump into the discussion
and we really really value everyone's
feedback so bizarre ideas outlandish
ideas everything is welcome do you have
any ideas mr. house I'm waiting for the
speed Hess Championships to someone to
write that because but puns are non-stop
people always like hey Robert did you
know if your first name started with a
see that your name would be chess I'm
like no nobody's ever said some more
tell me more that's actually really
interesting I've never heard that one
but I actually have you know maybe if I
make this request publicly Chazz like um
we'll do it I would love to see a
chess960 official random speeches
championship I think you gotta be a lot
of fun you would see some of the top
players in the world losing a couple
moves just because they're like wait
what's what's happening here and we had
the Fischer random World Chess
Championship which was a fidei event
where what's the sound of beating -
cause the final but I think it'd be so
fun in a speech chess champion format or
just a variance will you play king of
the hill you've got three checks it
could just be for pure entertainment the
players don't have to prepare there's
nothing serious going on and I think you
get the best time for everybody when
everybody's relaxed absolutely one other
idea that
was maybe a senior speech Chess
Championship there are some players in
semi-retirement I'm thinking larry
christensen yon Elvis just beasts of
American chess
now Larry Christensen for example a
bullet legend I want to see them come
out and play some place of blitz so that
would be another idea so so many
interesting concepts we on everybody to
jump in do you feel that that is the
producers and the tech team kicking you
saying you really want to create work
more work for us because as soon as you
start putting people who may not be so
used to using the technology hey it's
more work for them that's that's a great
point Robert I I'll consider it very
very carefully before making suggestions
means that we have some Cheston and
hissing to do we do let's get the chest
going
Teddy Cole meets the white pieces in
this game he's yeah he's tied with levy
after 22 straight games there so the
momentum shifting it's winking in
Teddy's favor and we had this position
which I know Teddy has been studying as
of late and we have B takes c3 so this
would be takes to the Queen takes to see
the reason option B takes season 3 I
can't speak B takes c3 pawn b2 captured
on c3 that's what happened Vaughan
captures which fun I don't think you
made that clear now the b2 pawn that's
no longer there captured on c3 okay and
look at the central controlled by these
pawns like D for D found here's E for
this is the plan and Magnus has made
lines of he's very popular where he says
I just clamping down on the center of
the board making blacks life as
difficult as possible and Levy going for
a quick f5 and for Teddy is he gonna
consider night h4 here trying to stop
that five yeah this is very annoying
yeah fives a very annoying idea because
you know some of the bishop eg to have
five if white if white centre collapses
things could spiral out of control very
quickly I like that H for question 4
levied as he played g6 97 to reinforce
the idea about fiber does he try to to
find a way to play a5 faster you know 5
in this position is not out of the
question he does play g6 sort of Kings
Indian style but he's gonna feel in
Cairo his knight rather than his bishop
would be my guess or play a5 immediately
nothing wrong with that either
well the downside of f5 is
first official ng2 is very happy in such
a position so he fiend ket is that night
but the problem with playing King's
Union style when you don't have a dark
square bishop yes the dark starfish one
g7 often stinks in the King's Indian
because behind your pawn wall but
without it the h6 Square is one that
that 1 c1 will land on in the near
future
yeah exactly which which means by
definition f5 introduces all these
weaknesses and Levy he delays f5 which i
think is kind of wise he's insinuating
Bishop h3 Teddy doesn't mind though if
Teddy drives upon to f5 that could be
huge trouble for blacks so Bishop h3
here's a no-go for sure I like a fight
this was the last opportunity I do like
Teddy's position here because if he
opens up the center you know those
bishops should make their presence felt
that semi-open be file he puts a rook on
b1 he's starting to add some heat to
this position levees got to be very
precise here I think roof b1 just
hitting that pawn on b7 b6 cannot be
played so actually that rook me one move
is quite annoying because you keep that
Queen stuck to the pawn rook b8 well now
you have a passive rook compared your
funds more active work on b1 and we see
a pre move of Bishop takes d4 it seems
tasty a little better at the bullet
Hanyu weird flex but okay yeah he is no
of course it's it's very wise to pre
move as much as you can the safe free
moves should always be made because you
might be Oh what does it matter but it
always does matter when it comes down to
three minutes and below every half
second matters in terms of having that
accumulated time at the end of the game
or when the game gets very tense but now
some problems to solve for Teddy to see
play Bishop b3 here just developing I
certainly wouldn't wouldn't advise
taking on e5 just yet
maybe just a developing move what what
are your thoughts about this position
Robert well taking on e5 allows the
knight to jump into e5 but it does allow
your Bishop to get active over there on
the King's I mean Bishop g5 at some
point trying to get to be f6 where a
Queen eight for taking your advice is
not clarifying the center just yet I was
think of Knight f3 to g5 is rerouting
this night is done its job on h4
let me go to g5 oh okay Bishop e7 did I
just worry about this d5 squared yeah
as if this night can go to g5 then
there's going to be trouble
so if 57 is there any good discovery for
black like is there a threat is my
question yeah I'm not seeing I'm not
seeing anything super convincing him in
Teddy again goes for sort of the safe
option I'm not sure that there was very
much in the way of a threat now let me
jumps in with night at 5 9 f3 here I
think again Robert that g5 square
mmm I'm not sure I like that that night
would have allowed white to chisel his
way into blacks King side now he doesn't
have one of those tools I really like
that Bishop on at five as well I'm
thinking also about Bishop c6 and pawn
takes d5 stuff so he doesn't do it but
if we just look at that line for a
second if he played Bishop c6 b c6 me
traded the rooks
taking on e5 and just say hey I'm
ruining your pawn shops or your King on
g7 is in a vulnerable spot it's a mutual
vulnerability on the theme keto King
size because you don't have that feeling
kiddo Bishop but instead Teddy saying
I'm keeping my two bishops I think
there's actually way smarter just to
maintain the pressure the knight on c6
has nowhere to go
the a7 pawn will fall if you move that
night away so there's F takes d5 threats
there's pawn to d4 at the right moment
when you're not pinned so he's keeping
his options open here yep a lobby to I'm
think about that g3 Square
it doesn't work as my working affluence
hanging with ya there was the hessin
part but not the Chesson part there
exactly I was just going for jerks hey
they say tricks are for kids but I want
to be a kid sometimes too me too
maybe up takes e5 though and Bishop d4 I
don't know about that it's a
double-sided sword he does go up take C
find out D takes e5 would create all of
these new weaknesses including that on
now Bishop e7 first know there's Bishop
e3 that doesn't work
Queen d2 also is a move to consider with
Bishop h6 j ah yeah that those squares
around blacks King but Bishop t4 by
Teddy c6 now you can just drop the
Bishop back to teach you obviously you
cannot take on d3 because of that pen
maybe King g8 just resolving those
problems once and for all should be
considered and he does so rabida d1 is
you know not a move you're happy to play
but just a move to try to protect that
square there it's played and both sides
in 34 second territory I like the way
levy has fended off Teddy because we
both liked his position it's felt like I
don't want to
Danya about the opening okay take on a
seven it says that out of the question
absolutely not but see for I not I mean
look at White's positions very very
solid maybe dystrophy 794 there's Queen
b3 Queen b3 so you're getting women
haven't see five four black just trying
to trap this bishop in here I like it
he's got a try that otherwise Bishop
drops back is there any alternative page
three also trying to massage those
squares around White's King but ladies
got to make a decision he's down almost
below ten seconds now why don't we go
again belts fastened and mandatory so I
think you have to go Bishop to b6 at
some moment I didn't like we should be
five it's not the move that I was thrown
in because that Bishop age three feels
me as vulnerable for white so Bishop d6
you need to save this Bishop and I know
it's the only way I see how to do it
Queen B to played the d3 pawn is now
under attack so I don't like this at all
Forte before we barely got that move off
you know d4 I couldn't move now he's
trying to evacuate the bishop and levy
93 that looks so flimsy though it really
does rook takes a 5-2 threat to win the
knight on d3 can you go rook at five now
but doesn't have you want rook e1 does
Ruby does a tricky one now look up one
though I'm in still rook e1 oh gosh oh
man King G to ruins the queen of the
game it's just the game oh wow what a
what a devilish move by levy
so understated rook e8 it seems like he
blunders she had it all planned out with
two seconds on the clock another
frustrating loss we ready pull up the
analysis board really quickly as this
game gets underway and we have a bishops
opening and Teddy goes out for that
Bishop but on the analysis port check
what happened here we were talking about
this night on d3 rook e8 was playing
rook takes as five doesn't work and if
birthdays 5 doesn't work the threat of
rookie 2 is so powerful for black it did
feel like things were starting to go
whites way after the Bishop got trapped
in a 7 but he was fighting its way out
unfortunately we tell you Brooke t25 was
a tempting thing that I suggest as well
but it fell to the quick checkmate and
you lose all pieces so now we have this
game here which was my childhood'
opening levees playing this from the
white side and I have to admit I don't
like it after Josh freed L schooled me
from the black side of this and honestly
my Medea Polito at some point too if I'm
remembering correctly giving up the
bishop pair may not look like a problem
when the position is so close the c4 and
E for
phones are clamping down on the center
saying hey you're not breaking through
here buddy but as time goes on and the
board opens up if you cast some play for
f5 for instance then those bishops are
very happy pieces exactly I've
experimented with this in blitz but this
idea of preparing t5 constantly hangs
over white so it's you know levy in the
previous game did a very good job of
reaching a position that's just not
Teddy's cup of tea and that's really
paying off and speaking of cups of teas
I will get my cup of tea and put you
behind the wheel for about 10 seconds I
know everybody will miss me dearly but I
shall be back yeah just leave already so
now it's just me and a thigh played by
Teddy just to try to fight for some
space on the Queen side the d6 pawn
Queen c7 you step out of the pin if you
do not play Queen to c7 here comes c5
and then I'm trying to get after this
pin pawn so crazy seven plate it's not
easy to put more pressure on this pawn
you play Queen d3 always have work to do
a knight g3 g6 is a good move stopping
this Knight from any forward progress we
say this so frequently a pawned three
squares away from a knight often
dominates that night midnight on g3 I
hear that you're back Tania so of course
feel free to you know further emphasize
RT is over or has it just begun Bishop
d6 but that's a double-sided sword Queen
f6 castles maybe yeah Queen f6 either
Castle just move your rook somewhere
like rook to f8 and then play for Bishop
b4 and this Knight is a little loose but
now something feels like it should be
good for white but you need to make up
precise moves something is rotten in the
state of Denmark
yeah rook GG there this distinct smell
of tactics is in the air the problem is
I just don't quite see it maybe
everything is protective but now castles
I think would actually be a big mistake
do tonight at five that's what I was
smelling there and GF GF and rook G one
comes and mates your King so quickly so
rook G it actually quite important and
you know oftentimes the King is safer in
the center then if you had committed it
to one flank in there we have it Teddy
very careful in these positions so
that's the strength of this he doesn't
beat himself when he's got a lot of time
on the clock rukia was actually a very
good move because it stops the Queen him
coming to g7
Burke could potentially take on h6 and
he doesn't need a castle he might if you
take on da take by the with the king and
everyone that came to see it castle by
hand but watch out for h5 striking on
the kingside White has sort of
overextended on that side the boards of
h5 and with a rook on g8 trying to open
that G file it can become quite
dangerous for y2 the extra pawn look at
it as a pawn on c4 not really doing all
that much just yet but I like this move
Queen III trying to go Queen a7 or if
you give me a pawn in 6 yeah I like
Queen e3 as well I think it's it's wise
it stabilizes this is the situation
h5 though by Teddy like what he's doing
here he's making that adjustment seizing
the ax 2 tactical opportunity rather
than playing it safe in certain
positions so that's a positive maybe f3
but then that weakens that g1 a7
diagonal and b-66 gave me that Bishop to
c5 I've been begging for an active
diagonal and I will take it right away
yup and that Bishop on c5 it's like a
Manhattan parking spot once you buy it
it's yours I don't know much about
Manhattan parking spots but I heard they
go for a million dollars he took at h5
but I think he did that too quickly
after g h5 couldif lead Bishop takes h3
there and just I feel like he could yeah
and then wrong do you want Chuck simply
king CA but then Queen a7 idea it starts
to look a little hairy any h6 you can
keep that pawn going as a decoy so
perhaps he was just saying I'll take
back and look at that white Kegel I
didn't even see Bishop g5 but he comes
Bishop f4 the downside of taking on h5
for white is abundantly clear once that
bishop lens on f4 and Teddy it's hard to
get a read on what he's thinking he's
he's doing all sorts of facial
acrobatics but I'm king c8 I mean if
Queen a7 see the thing the benefits flag
here is Queen a a check can always be
met with Queen BA and the party keeps
going in the endgame for black those
bishops just slicing through White's
position it's very hard to evade all of
the pins without giving up material
Teddy employee chooses King EE which is
interesting I suppose but what about
Queen a7 now how exactly does black deal
with all of that still still Bishop f4
yeah bishops coming in for no matter
what and the problem for why is Queen a7
Bishop f4 Knight c3 to e2 it looks like
you're getting rid of this piece but
first of all of you
I'll take with the e pawn attacking some
more but h4 metaphor h6 g3 Intermezzo
right I have checked to your king and
then I take back on it for end of a
piece yup and levy going for the
stabilizing Queen f3 attacking age 5
this is the kind of position which could
really backfire for Teddy if he doesn't
act decisively I like this move Bishop
f4 not allowing the night to get to h5
maybe 10 lemme can just snap that fun on
h5 which he does oh my gosh I wish I
would have liked Queen e7 Queen to f6
threatened rook AJ and just go after the
h3 point mm-hmm well not everybody can
be 8 seconds
okay sure oh that's slicing and dicing
here King G to rook h3 can't get out of
all the pins King g1 wreckage 3 and then
g3 is gonna fall very grim oh this is
not good
okay so rook each four threads Bishop g4
I don't know if it's in time
but I'm just thinking can I go after
this Queen what else can black do here
because my team support is a big threat
I love her a cage for cuz but then even
but then maybe night a for a night of
five if he takes up four okay the Queen
is no threats the black Queen covers d8
so you're safe for the moment but that
was a very good move and very quick
Mumbai levy 23 he's just so strong an
acute time pressure now c5 is in the mix
as a possibility to ward off blacks
Queen because the queen is tied down to
the d8 square I think I overestimated
and there it is here's Queen c7 just
retreat that Queen you can't a lot check
we know one there's nothing else nothing
about have to move off at Queen e7 I
like that one I'm sorry this is so crazy
now take some stuff every week exactly
start on and bone immediately yeah
because you trade a Knight a5 good call
submission rep oh oh he's just barely
getting slack and now we have even
material but two seconds for white ten
seconds for black rook at four check and
then Bishop h4 but his native five
coming here's Knight a5 identify by game
Teddy's starting to let the slip Oh 1963
f3 what about much
Knights have for the night come sir and
the victory tour begins for the night
look at this take it and play a five you
have to play a five and rook up sticks
as a passive movie you had to play a
five you open things up and here the
rooks coming over g6 come to g2 they're
definitely chances to hold for black
mr. g5 okay mr. B one protecting eight
five tickets e2 that's a free pawn you
gotta fight for this one oh that's not
bad now I have five rookie three okay
he's going for the works III or ever
second he's poor or seconds to time
pressure the world stops what has
happened
Teddy wins the time scramble somebody I
don't know what just happened how why
what Tania world is upside down how did
that happen that is Teddy's first
victory to time scramble I think I've
ever seen I ever second that and Teddy
just leaning back I think he might have
thought he lost some time and then he
was he thought wait a second no no no it
was the other way around I think he's in
as much disbelief as your efforts oh my
gosh what a crazy game that was where
Teddy seemed like he's in the driver's
seat credit to Levy and that was amazing
defense in what turned out to be a tough
position for him and the opening I don't
think is one that we will necessarily
see let me repeat it just didn't really
look good for him you know he won a pawn
and even after winning the pawn his
position still looked kind of rough so
right it's a levy for fighting that one
out and somehow Teddy Coleman won a time
scream I'm still I you take the reigns
here Danya I'm shot no I am as well I
mean but again hats off to levy those
were some Cirque du Soliel were the
acrobatics with his pieces in two
seconds on the clock getting mated he
finds a way out
you know the frustration is palpable but
I mean there have been so many we you've
mentioned in the five minute Orton
Robert
those were the the least number of games
we've seen but that is because we're
seeing time scramble after time scramble
so much stress so much on the line
wait what about Queen a 495 Queen Queen
a four check was looking maybe Queen D
four at the end provided teddy is making
the adjustments she didn't beat himself
in that game he kept playing and playing
he made a lot of mistakes but he got
rewarded in the end but this is not
looking good Bishop before he's giving
up a pawn speaking of mistakes somehow
he just lost a pawn in this opening she
did and he's buried that's a white plate
Queen e2 the thing is you have to Bishop
so I understand that blacks of the pawn
play Queen e2
castle plate quickly and then go for
something on the kingside right it's not
the worst pawn that you've ever lost and
there is clear counter play in the form
of two bishops
so just just go just go and I want I
don't want to stay for people who you
know are saying you know go easy on
Teddy Teddy is one of my lifelong best
friends for those of you who are not
aware and we've played many blitz games
and Teddy he I really have never seen
him win a time scramble so I am shocked
that that just happened and for levy
Levy was living on the increment
multiple games in this match and that
was the first time he's actually let his
clock fall so lemme you know again he's
in time trouble here diamond he's down
but 45 seconds on the clock so I what do
you make of this what's this dynamic
like are they just trying to get us hype
for the bullet portion of this match
yeah that's Teddy Rosman against Levy
Coleman here and let me again I've been
beyond impressed with his ability to to
make the most out of two seconds
situations were I would have either
Bunner made on the next move or lost one
time nerves of steel at the same time I
feel like he has to get out of his head
a little bit play a little more
confidently we saw him start off the
match playing quickly in the opening I
think he has to find the middle ground
there I still think he's the favorite in
bullet but it he's gonna be fine with an
even score coming into the bullet
segment I think that's how confident
levy should be in his bullet prowess but
with 26 minutes left this is where I
think Teddy has got to make the push to
get a 2/3 point cushion coming into the
bullet segment and I see great comment
by Daniela Queen in the chat this looks
a bit like the line in the vienna where
white sacrifices the e pawn that's
actually a really good call it looks a
lot like that where all of a sudden
Yvonne's gone but White has the two
bishops
and some clear play and I'll actually
that line there is not the two bishops
because bishop goes did you a knight
takes either BC Bishop back to e7 I
don't know about a 45 though levy just
made the face you make when somebody
orders a burger and a seafood restaurant
like not quite enough spice there but
still some pressure going and that is
indeed a great comparison why it's
always going to have compensation here
as long as the center is open
the species are active with rookie 51
for example yeah rook F do you want
Bishop d6 comes to mind just to plant
that bishop in then 95 to follow in some
variations in fact Bishop d6 rook e8 95
is interesting indeed I like this
actually
c5 might have been a little bit rash
maybe I mean it's easy for me to say
Teddy again starting to pile up maybe a
6 here
ooh a 6 it taught me to play can I take
you on a 6 you just give me a show have
three did blunder that Robert I did
blunder that I guilty as charged I
appreciate your honesty it still looks
very interesting in black will certainly
fight on in a line like that but I just
figured there we see it well might be
follows you know the best can I thought
was the Danya school of chess is what
you're saying
the wanderin call it and plan it off
pawn it off as a sacrifice or shall I
say pawn it off as a sacrifice anyways
let me stop that entire train of thought
before it gets out of hand
oh man and Knight to d5 so wait what's
the situation now white no even I was
like wait is upland but there should be
seven i these two bishop is against you
Knights always leads to the most complex
of positions that pawn on c5 if it
reaches c7 that's a problem but White's
king is not a not comfortable either
this is anyone's game
the remaining d6 is such an excellent
piece it is Oh
but nice find oh if Bishop takes d5
they're like weensie five check and then
you could take on d5 with your queen
that's really nice geometry there
good observation I think c6 I like I
think he has to try it and take on b7
Queen b6 here and good we can I have
some kind of no BA doesn't work I was
trying to play a rupee one type of thing
yes I'm afraid II asked him of his
Bishop back but the plus side is a5
falls and he's got that C pawn which is
also passed
I guess a5 doesn't fall immediately but
it is a weak fun White's got to be
better here and the f3 pawn we've seen
this actually several times today where
the double f3 pawn is really nice look
at the fun of three covers against that
9 + f6 now white is up a past C pawn and
if you get your rooks behind the pawns
are pushing it that's when the magic
starts to happen and rook c8 just
stopping it okay
whatever night be three that is a four
yep Queen III is stabilizing move now
rook do you want for example and then
rook T six comes in the problem is black
is no supports for his Knight
so as soon as white you know takes one
brick out of the structure here we see
ninety seven that pawn on c4 if handled
wisely can't decide the game Bishop e5
here good good move as well he's also
got the time edge but who knows what's
gonna happen we've seen all sorts of
things in these time scrambles right
whatever this rook and c1 teen a3 oh and
now this ladies and gentlemen
buckle in got queasy for you you have to
protect that c5 pawn you cannot afford
to lose he finds coatings before night
Nevada in the night Knight f4 becomes in
the future possibility queens of three
Queen six of 300 misses and c6 that pawn
is passed what is happening levy is just
not looking at the clock and somehow you
know maybe it's like a law of averages
type of thing where levy is an immense
time trouble every single game and it's
really coming back to bite him and let
me roll his eyes crack his neck and he's
just like what the heck is going on I
need to get things in order Queen f3
Robert I think that was that might
almost have been winning for black
because night afore there was such a
devastating threat and and levy is he's
just lost the thread a little bit here
yet again he has to put things in
perspective it's only a one point lead
for Teddy but the world has shifted on a
Texas Teddy his has won two games in a
row by time forfeit never thought we'd
live to see the day I mean seriously I'm
just in other disbelief right now but
kudos of both of these players for
giving us an absolute show and levies
just at one point in the match and Danya
as we get closer closer to the bullet
section how many games can levy be down
and you still consider him the favorite
against teddy considering that levy is
the better bullet player I think within
- I think if levy is down by two points
he still has the edge in bullet I think
starting at three points that's when
things get concerning for lady I just
and again I'm not trying to minimize the
effort City has put in here which has
been immense he's played faster and more
accurately than even than he did against
Danny the problem is I've played levy
hundreds of Bullock
a guy is a speed demon and he's able to
maintain a very high degree of accuracy
so I'm not gonna make any global
predictions here but I feel like you
know I feel like the bullet could be
influenced by the emotional state of the
players so you know it's not the same as
if they were just to sit down and play a
bullet match the pre the results of the
previous segments always influences the
dynamic of the bullet section so that's
kind of complicate matters for leve if
if he does find himself in a situation
where he needs to mount a comeback
indeed and I just wanna give a shout out
to the chest TV chatter see all you
there and that's Katarina I see you Koch
guy you guys are so much fun to listen
to dr. Kate you're so much fun to listen
to I got a message you and talk to she's
fantastic
a player on the u.s. women's team and
it's just a great person and chats
everybody who's tuning in here we have
many thousands of you I've done math in
a while so I don't want to add up the
numbers across the platforms but we're
in for what will be a wild finish
because if the start is any indication
pieces will be flying people will be
losing on time and I'm just not gonna
know what to do with myself I mean yeah
this is this is this is incredible
it's late evening here in the East Coast
so we do appreciate so many of you along
with us along for the ride in it and
it's been a roller coaster in the
morning and our roller coaster and
evening I like Queen h5 there this is a
Java London that has gone quite wrong
for for teddy I feel like he's played a
little too conservatively I like ladies
chances here he's got big pressure
coming on the Kings side and h5 I'm not
sure where's that pressure coming from
because you're punky v is always one
that needs an I kept on it and Knight c5
if you want to take off this Bishop on
d3 it is a plan I am worried that you
are going to squished on the Kings side
if you're black in a move like f6 at the
right moment might need to be played
just to challenge why it's very
impressive
structure on that side of the board and
f6 actually generally speaking is a
pretty useful movie if you can make it
work and now row page three the cannons
come out very classical rook lifts to g3
the time situation this time definitely
favoring levy Teddy's got to make
something happen either in the center
with c5 or with a move like f6 he just
cannot tread water for much longer
because his king is in is in grave
danger yes and f6 is funny moving pawns
in front of your king is often a no-no
when you're under attack but you know
that at the higher levels it's often use
as a defensive measure gaining some
activity for your pieces on the same
side of the board you're under attack is
a useful strategy King h8 played just
getting out the way for now it doesn't
really seem to me what's the plan there
with rook g3 is there some kind of Queen
h4 is he waiting enticing his opponent
to move that rook away I suppose now
Queen F fives and then there we see it
at five this doesn't solve I should
mention also the positional nature
favours what it takes like takes f6
there in Queen g3 that would have just
sliced through that diagonal and if that
was a big mistake big mistake by levy
Teddy's got to be breathing a sigh of
relief or am I missing something you're
not missing anything and the whole plan
is Bishop g5 Bishop f6 and Queen g6
ideas but as long as that Queen keeps an
eye I don't know maybe 92 night of 4 but
I can get my knight to e8 so if you go
Bishop f6 check I'll go King g8 and then
go 98 so 92 f4 makes me a lot of sense
here and the big problem for Teddy is
this Bishop on d7 if he can somehow
activate that piece then he has better
chances but for now he's just sitting
behind his pawns a5 here
okay there's counter play that's the
counter play you need down the a file
that second Front has been opened and we
talked about this before sometimes you
get so infatuated with your plan one
flank the other flank becomes abandon
that that's exactly what Teddy
exploiting here now maybe after a
level-headed move like row to c1 White's
still got the advantage I don't think
there's any doubt about that
well IV does precisely that but this is
the trend isn't Teddy's favor here he's
just got to play fast the prom he's
facing is he wants to move his knight
out of the way and swing his f8 rook to
the a file double me a fond good counter
play but as soon as you move that night
away from get your word up left 6
check
so right now Teddy's in a tough spot
here how do I actually continue amount
of pressure no this easy bishops case
between 87 and he plays c5 just trying
to open up some squares and d4 I like
this but it's too much
I mean there's just not enough grounds
to start a fire you know he's got the
fun d5 now but he's dawns upon c6
comes in hey he didn't start the fire it
was always burning oh that's
that's genius I don't think I can say
anything
the rest of this commentary that is
going to match jeonyul you say it best
when you say nothing at all that I have
that I will say nothing at all that is
rather than speak and remove all doubt
as they say and here comes the rook to
a3 hitting the d3 pawn do you need to
protect that point just take some beef
for route 63 is the next one for c3
trying taking on c5 Roby fc6 rook d7
there would have been good as well yeah
that actually look really strong of you
c6 move because now if I do get it stomp
on me
I did I didn't I always knew that's you
know at the end of the day you're on my
side I am the rook on h3 is awkward so
who and now a pin Queen d7 what a way to
save that actually ladies yeah 96 looks
good I mean even if that night on f8 is
capture that pawn on e5 is gonna ship to
e6 I don't know about that still
completely dominating look at know that
rookie that's an excellent movie you
need to forgive you rook f7 bring it no
I don't like you opt for now rook t4 yes
you need rook F 757 you need to
challenge that rook there white rook d7
immediately okay and games the light
square domination the knight will help
you survive so Queen up for Queen takes
t4 but so many weaknesses Queen c3 how
are you defending these long-term
threats of Queens da I'm not I don't
know how and I'm probably not but I'm no
king of seven oh wow that was a big
decision and I don't see how you win
this I was very committal and oftentimes
the blockade supersedes even the manage
King D 7 did nice trapped but still how
do you know you bring the king to d4 now
10 you get away with this
leave say yeah the King were no this is
lost g4 you've been preparing g4 is
winning yes or this bringing the King to
d4 inducing Zubaz Vaughn
remember that was that was great by levy
understand the knight was trapped
yeah great understanding and he saw that
so quickly that position really quickly
started interrupt you've done you know I
just want to show that one more time the
understanding cuz I was saying that you
can't trade Queens cuz the light score
blockaded and if that night could get
out then you would get a blockade but
said Bishop d8 this Knight is completely
stuck the white pawns cover its escape
squares and the bishop does the rest
really nicely done by levy in that
endgame and now we have a position where
we're tied in the match levy gets two
black pages here
Teddy going for his d4 stuff Danya and
the floor is you're sorry for being
long-winded there you better be sorry we
have a Carl spot and I think every time
they've entered something like this they
have deviated here we have a pure Carl
spot structure which we saw several
times in the morning we saw that
scintillating game between Alena and
Eric where Eric pulled a Cossack or Lee
this was a SOT so I lead her for mine
here we see g6 by leve D I used to play
Knight g7 potentially and swing that
night around to have five so I always am
biased in favor of white here I feel
like that idea of e4 just comes more
naturally than blacks play but if black
understands these positions and my very
committal but what do you make of that
Robert does why I'm lucky for here just
blast things open yeah that move just
scares me to look at because I'm looking
at g4 I'm looking at E for and I
completely agree with your point Don
it's easier to play these positions from
the white side because blacks plan is
really about stopping white from playing
in the center with E 4 and then may play
c5 at the right moment but white does
have more activity Knight f6 play h3
like calm and you don't have to play e4
it necessarily from the white side of
things but maybe this is we talk about
how in some positions where levy has
gone forward on the Kings side and then
he sort of paid the price because he's
overextended
maybe Teddy's gonna pay the price
because g4 is a very committal decision
Castle young it is yes it absolutely is
but I still like it I feel like see
blacks King has really nowhere to run
because castling long creates its own
set of problems connected with b4 b5
castling short its own problems with
Bishop 6 g6 leaving the King in the
center Y can play e4 so just that
dynamic and White's King a lot safer
than its colleague still I would counsel
long if I were black what do you make of
that problem Robert isn't should levy
just Castle long or if I never heard
opposing Kings be called colleagues
because aren't they kind of inherently
at odds with each other
did I say V Xavi
[Laughter]
the kingís safe is an adhesive easily on
ba Tennessee's you shouldn't they be
severe Shakey's venetie and then just
apologize to me - yeah wow that is
impressive and that is good
pronunciation - that means I apologize
- should I like it wherever does that
you know you're really working for other
words of affirmation from me they're not
girls well in informs zelich apology too
late to apologize it's all your MV else
it I just have that song stuck in my
head now it's too late to apologize
Oh God let me table let me grab some
baguettes and some day of the year and
enjoy this position for white ROC 5 now
that is d5 square if I want to take 3 6
I really want to take on g6 now in okay
that's why he took with a queen on c5 I
would think because of Knight takes e5
Bishop g6 check HD 6 Queen G 16 d8 I
assume because King f8 looks like it's
running to the F file then 95 and all of
a sudden your Kings being hunted very
quickly here what did I just do I put a
certain song and certain people said but
shout out to Jennifer Shehadeh if you
have so many great people watching this
match
big big honor to commentate to you guys
and just a huge shout out once again to
everybody watching this this fascinating
match and I have a feeling were once
again going to be down to the wire but
this position is this is very very scary
for levy I mean things threaten to just
collapse after E for which Teddy is just
prepared with his last move and unlike
what I would do for you I'm going to
apologize to Jen show howdy for getting
the song stuck in your head
nobody wants that - I'm gonna play
Bishop takes she's six here how do I
take five Knight takes you five venue
for does that work obey your Bishop g6
move that's also just I'd begrudgingly
have to admit that you've come up with
something decent and so II for play d4
d5 tell you just throwing his pawns for
it because now d4 is hanging that is
actually really smart because after
Queen 65 94 94 Bishop b4 Queen D for his
bishop things g6 check and the Queen on
d4 is lost indeed
and this is just the center opens and
all of these holes and I mean this is
come this is so overwhelming this is
where I remind people of that story I've
told too many times on Bishop g6 is just
your science of where I was playing
someone who literally took out a camera
and photograph the position in the
moment when I was lost absolutely true
story that game is in the database - did
you see levees reaction by the way when
Bishop takes g6 happened
he pulled a Laurence Trent but said
cowering in the corner he was just like
oh my gosh how could I miss that move
and you know he's an international
master you don't miss these kind of
moves very often but he was under
pressure from the start so kudos to
Teddy and Danya this is a back and forth
match up thus far we keep talking about
in the bullet portion it should be in
Levy's advantage but so far it feels
like I'm very evenly matched pair of
opponents indeed it does and Teddy I
think in the last couple of games he's
done a good job of turning the dial when
it comes to decisive action when he has
the initiative he's not letting as many
opportunities slip as he did at the
start and that's causing this awkward
momento for him the same time I'm going
to stand by what I said he's got to try
to extend this leap at the very least to
two points otherwise Levy's still gonna
be the clear favorite in the bullet but
we never know diploid surprises now as
you say I think this is a good
opportunity for him because he once
again has the black side of this line
where he has two bishops and the game is
not clear so sometimes there's you know
an outpost for a knight ask where your
knight needs to get to and you know on
flipside your blacks pieces don't
exactly know where they belong either
but I would go Queen c7 Castle queenside
and then try it at some point to make d5
happen and it's not going to be easy
it's what Teddy Coleman move I've ever
seen the what what to say I think we're
both speechless here Robert g5 I have
never in my whole life seen Teddy come
and make a move like that
that's what San Francisco does - I think
he's feeling a little cooped up you know
because quarantine eing and just staying
home you can't really leave and you're
trying to make sure that everything you
know everyone stays healthy and safe and
then you
g5e like yeah I wouldn't do that under
normal circumstances but it's not
actually that bad of a move
it just looks crazy whatever that shucks
shuka had that Teddy Teddy ate during
the last match I don't know maybe it
changed him but I don't like it I like
it me some of that I like what he's
doing here aged 5 and then f3 okay so
yeah and the problem is that f5 square
that g5 pawn could backfire a little bit
eh anyway brookey 7 for KJ double on the
H file hmm yeah he's got a decision to
make I like work h7 he can all I let
he's not threatening to take on g5 he
doesn't have any threats at the moment
it's just the long-term weakness of that
squaring f5 that Teddy's trying to patch
up with age for stomping 93 that
actually is quite clever stopping this
knife from getting to my fine but who is
who does the closing of the kingside
favorites it's hard to judge because
white does have that pressure on the D
file now his hands are on tied he can
focus on attacking that weak d6 pawn and
where's this night going the f6 excuse
me f8 g 6f 4 so something like that
that's what the knight is trying to go
the d6 pawn may be the easiest pawn to
put a pile of pressure I'm a bishop a3 a
timing Bishop e3 will not be fun for
black to me because oh and betrayed 3
now isn't going night c5
I think he's going nicely fun okay but
that's a little bit flimsy it's a little
bit flimsy maybe it's sturdier than
meets the eye initially I suppose so
it's it's it's hard because the white is
also kind of cramped right all of these
and Robert once again I never noticed
this before today but you mentioned the
pod 3 squares from the Knight d5 pawn to
you tonight
completely limits no Knight e3 no 94
here is there anything other than 95 I
don't think so
right because if you move the knight
backwards then the d6 pawn feels like a
really big target and then black will be
tied down at least on Knight c5 you can
you go shovel pieces maybe 6 going to c8
that makes a lot of sense to actually
that might even be better yep very very
solid and the reason why I like that
better is if in the case of Knight to c5
maybe what could have capture on c5 Trey
to the pieces say your bishops have
nowhere to work with and maybe just a
draw but I think that in Knight b6 you
you white well what exactly are you
doing from here where do you exactly and
it's very time-consuming to find ways to
keep the pressure going in certain ways
you can look at this and say our whites
got all the pressure here but it's a
it's a two-sided coin blacks reacting
white is the one who keeps having to
generate ideas c5 is interesting here it
simplifies the position I kind of like
the practical value of that move if the
Queen appears on c5 that's just gonna be
kind of annoying for black yes I'm the
bishop on e6 is one that is we talk
about Knights that are restricted look
at the pitch 26 know where to go for
that piece but Teddy trades on c5 his
knight c8 understanding if we get more
trades on d8 eventually up like Queen to
b6 and trade the Queen's off the border
at F trade the Queen's off the board and
if you can push quite Queen back fend
off that Queen where are you gonna make
progress from and I don't see a square
here yup rook d6 slowly but surely
emerging from the shell I saw I think
this is equal I mean I think this is a
high potential of fizzling out into a
draw but the way this match is going I
have a feeling some sort of Inferno is
going to be lit in the next couple of
moves this time scramble is gonna be led
as well because I know a time scramble
is coming Wow
and you're getting ready for krisily
hips match up by using words like lit
and night to d3 on I'm not entirely sure
I loved I just quote where than I going
from your net to be four okay I take it
back whichever night before and that's
really annoying because 96 nights just
chillin and vibe and on b4 actually
Queen d2 now we need to chiseling his
way inside once again Queen eight six
okay take a deep yep take on d2 now okay
take take twice and maybe six exactly we
saw at the same time you offer the Queen
trade in the Knights under attack okay a
hash tag we trade fam 85 and ignite away
that's not a hash tag stop it go away I
don't know how to use hash tags clearly
not and hash tag has sent interesting
just go away dude
I'm done with you who's better here
who's better winning chances
I think Robert has is better winning
chances I'm so over you man I hope can
can just like calm find me a new co
commentator please well
I'm the most interesting man in the
world who once said an awkward moment
just to see how it feels
eh for now I like that move what do you
make of I think Teddy's got the upper
hand now and once again looked at the
clock
he's taking it when a third game buy
time for a fit and he thought about a
three check but when you put upon a
three there's a pawn that might have
gone too far here comes the knight to e6
maybe to d4
okay that's progress and watch out look
in the clock look at the clock and watch
out for night III check if I can get
ninety four Queen eight three check I'm
sacking my queen there and four can you
on the c2 scores with c3 takes care of
that you're nobody on the night that I
don't date three losses that support I
feel like Teddy's got all these
maneuvers here Knight c5 there it is
nice find and what now there should be
six but again don't look at the clock
once again Oh 594 am I going to tying it
down and this is just over the time what
is happening this in the world oh my
gosh is just mastery by Teddy and an
Teddy with room to spare he was playing
those mopes instantly it reminds me of
what Alina was doing this morning just
piling the pressure both on the position
and on the clock just Teddy's on a roll
here and CC for b3 now starting to play
more experimental in the opening I think
he's confident once again he's gotta
keep striking while the iron is hot we
have a question by chess saying if Teddy
goes up by three hitting it's a bullet
is he the favorite
honestly it's lately in the time
scrambles Teddy has been the one you
know winning the games so Lemmy was the
one early in the match taking advantage
of mutual time pressure now it's been
all Teddy so I don't know what to think
in bullet Levy's rating is far higher
he's twenty-seven hundred plus name it's
150 in bullet Teddy's rating is
something like 23 fifty but with that
one second increment it's not pure
bullet you're not seeking to see as much
just you know flagging you can build up
some time it will be anyone's match but
Teddy has to be thrilled with how this
matches when he was down two games in
the five-minute portion now he's up two
games as we are deep and this is our
final game with a three-minute time
segment so yeah I mean Danya this is
crazy stuff it is but I should also
point out the levy you know I've known
for a long time
he and
and I don't say this about everybody I
certainly don't say this about myself
he's very composed it's hard to break
him and he's playing a good opening here
I like that Bishop on b7 you know with
one minute left this is probably gonna
be the last game I always say this but I
always mean it the last game of the
three-minute portion
especially when the match is closed
might very well carry the most
importance of any single game in the
match although obviously every game is
equally important in some sense but this
is what it's going to determine is the
brunt of the momentum coming into the
bullet portion I don't know what you
think about that Robert I just feel like
this game is carrying a lot of weight I
think that Teddy has to go full weird
al' yankovic and take the chevy to the
levee right now because you know he's up
two games the match winning this game
making a three that gives him some more
breathing room as we enter the bullet
portion so right now I don't love
White's position I'd actually think
black because I'm totally fine here but
maybes what kind of just nice III double
your own pawns in the D file and then
try to bring the knife into the center
yeah well at the same time levy yank
Jankovic Inge that Bishop away from d4
that's terrible 10:15 p.m. finally
failed the class funds 101 oh I made a
bad reference there hikaru coming in
yeah of course American Pie Don McLean
oh I was getting another one I've taken
a lap I'm taking a lap I am you know I
should have been more like Jason Biggs
knowing my American Pie but I just was
going with it so quickly it came to me
in the spur of the moment and Weird Al
is you know funky and I just it's
regrettable so anyway
Danya you take take the reins here
because I'm giving myself a self-imposed
timeout now that's what I like to hear I
was gonna make an incorrect reference as
well truth be told I was gonna make an
another one bites the dust reference
I feel like Al Yankovic did a spoof of
that as he did okay that's what I was
thinking about but then in carro pull
this super Jam rating on me and made me
insecure about my knowledge take that
mikaru come on man that's right I
thought I was thinking about so anyway
we have a 96 that I don't like that's
the song the placed in my head when I
lose the umpteenth game against mr.
Nakamura
another one by the way that's looking
amazing for teddy look at the harmony
and his pieces now what's the material
count cereal is even even so you know
black is quite solid here settings lower
on time but you can just sense the
confidence maybe he for to follow after
Queen h6 and watch out for Queen g3 with
a double attack on g7 and d6 of 27 Ron
said he was queasy 3 so now Knight to g7
is not really a threat because rook to
g8 will follow and pin the night but you
have to think about that Queen is being
an overloaded piece g6 those dark
squares Queen takes g6 watch out for it
okay now it's protecting the Queen so
Queen takes you six no longer yeah but
that was a huge filthy threat now how do
you improve the position for a way maybe
h4 is a little bit committal what else
h4 is played though I mean at the same
time he's clamping down on the g5 Square
white is not really in a hurry
everything is well protected you just
got to play faster and how do you keep
this going though because where does the
White King belong if the working were
already on c2 then I big all right that
king of safe and sound then I can go
forward with an attack on the Kings at
me now a Queen g5 type an idea but then
the knight will come to have 7 p.m. and
upon g5 well it opens up the H file it's
a double isolated pawn situation or it's
not easy to fence yeah
safe and sound indeed and the King
definitely belongs anywhere but a
capital city
ROK's doubled on e1 okay that was
terrible that was I'm going to self
quarantine my reference that was the
most that was the worst wind up in the
worst delivery it's okay I'm freaking I
don't like they record I don't like
baseball anyway so wind up and
deliveries and on board 95 coming that's
gonna be and 9h 694 that and I'd have 7
a devilish little move by levy Oh with
that King on f2 what is what is that
move I don't like that and I don't like
it either but I don't see but what about
F takes c4 ah there's a trick here's a
Fe for d4 96 runs in the e5
because if we start swapping on e5 a
bunch of times the end of it there's no
g6 check and
very nice 95 chosen by levy keeps the
tension maybe he's with one eye looking
at Teddy's clock now Knight g4 he takes
a five rookie to and there's no rookie
to because of Quinn a 100 Dan Hydra here
danger foretell he takes it he takes it
but do you sit with a knight on you to I
guess I guess Oh
checkmate is quit a 1 a 1 we need one is
check-in mateys I don't like up there
let me found it I think huge win oh gosh
that is a huge victory for leve Rossum
the net energy for coming to the rest
are we hated on d6 and improved its
South by getting to g4 and with that
levee cuts the deficit of one game we
saw that fist pump that was a little
klay Thompson type this bum here and
he's only down one point heading into
the bullet force we will be back in just
a few minutes and we return we will see
if levy brother came out the full come
back and defeat Teddy Coleman or once
again Teddy Coleman can surprise us all
by taking out a worthy I am in a bullet
event stay tuned everybody
[Music]
and we return here we just have one time
segment remaining that is the 25 minutes
of bullet chest and if you look at the
player cards for these two competitors
we note that between the two leve
rossman is clearly the superior bullet
player he has played so many games here
on chess calm he streams while playing
bullet half the time and his rating is
twenty seven fifty two so Danya we see
his rating we see Teddy's rating I mean
does Teddy have a chance
absolutely and there is no denying Levy
is a bullet beast
I've played him thirty-second chest 15
second chest one minute chest
he is incredibly fast his intuition is
good we see Teddy 23:36 bullet however
that doesn't tell the whole story in
Robert we've seen all sorts of things
happen today Teddy has been able to
raise the speed he's won many of these
time scrambles he stepped up as his
speed game so and he has of course still
the lead in the match so if this is
going to be very very close maybe
undeniably the favorite but Teddy is
capable of anything and he's clearly in
good for him today he is in leve was the
high rated blitz player in that didn't
stop Teddy from taking the five and
three minute portions with the +1 score
for Teddy so anything it happening the
bullet and anything should happen
because I'm ready for liftoff we are
gonna try to cover this as best as
possible if you're new to the channel if
you're new to bullet it's going to be a
lot of fun it's not going to be as good
for coaching and learning things but
we'll do our best we'll we will probably
be shouting sorry to everybody of your
neighborhood of mine
my apologies in advance but this is
really going to be a fun finish in dunya
I have to say I'm worried about Teddy's
chance he's only one point to
disappointing finish so three-minute
portion and we're off taste ours black
pieces 25 minutes of madness await and
indeed lower your headphone volume
ladies and gentlemen because I can sense
that this is going to get interesting in
another Joe Baba London by levy this
worked out very well for him in that
blitz game where he basically ran
circles over teddy on the Kings side
this time Teddy decides to take on it
for immediately
like that decision quickly striking the
center with c5 yes a very good decision
might say 92 is in by C 4 don't trap
your own Bishop very common theme and
certain French positions instead we see
a capture on d4 and that comes into c5
going after this Bishop I tend to like
these positions from the black side we
talked with us earlier when we looked at
Eric Rosen's match up with Alina cashton
sky a 5 what Alina did in those
positions as well trying to trade off
the bishop for the bishop rather than
the night
oh the C 6 squares juicy though yep
that's a knife that's a potential knife
now with that being said it's not like
the knight on c6 immediately causes
danger to black Teddy can put his own
knight on e4 he's gotta watch that
defiled him to say that immediately
tactics along the D file here could
become a problem with the Queen on on d6
for example 94 in the knight c6 already
threatens Queen 64 it doesn't let me
start with g3 which battle him to take
with the Queen on c3 I'm not sure the
Queen wants to be on c3 because you can
put a knight on c6 but I'm going to play
97 98 I cannot allow this like to stay
on the c6 square and here it comes
here comes 98 next move don't fall I
thought Queen a3 might have been better
97 97 oh that is that is a blend here
and see 46 might come in well c4 imma
take it with oh okay so now 94 96 maybe
this is not over yet
I don't like 93 rookie 3 and B 4 just
break through there and it's still not
over because my knight goes to e4 and
your f2 Colin is a bit of a problem it
exactly and you might notice
Teddy's actually play much faster than
Levy but a very good point raised by
Charlotte chess center in the chat my
good friend FM Peter G notice that flag
I mean one plus one is a completely
different animal from one plus zero you
can afford to get very low on the clock
here as we've seen levy do time and time
again in this match and he's pulled a
lot of these out but this is gonna be
hard to crack surprisingly enough yes
and the rook went back to d1 because b
for the C pawn would have been pinned
now before it can be played with beef
where this rook takes me 5 and all of a
sudden Teddy wins one one pawn you have
a knight and a pawn for a rook that is
good compensation the Knights come to d6
and actually watch out for that we're
getting trapped or some kind of a t4 and
that's gonna be 5 - yes that man was all
of us is white even better here I not 96
watch out for next c4 I see 4 and rugby
565 just rook takes me 5 and a B to
revert back to
father c-3po Newsweek now Knight c4 and
if b1 Knight d2 you can at least make a
draw there repeating the Murray seconds
and that night is running circles all
over the guy like that mood of this
blockade b-58 for coming in and can wait
look at this you might do anything
93 check a night back to c4 for instance
or a night back to f5 oh you're going
for the weed trying to I would start
with King d6 Robert I wouldn't rush here
because because of the time situation
don't force levy into forced moves
improved the position first and that's
what Teddy's trying to do we have to sit
careful you have six and I want to play
e5 at some moment I don't know if it
works he plays it right now and drop it
d4 just go d4 break over the 3rd rank I
don't like it for as much were that
gives the rook some air but that real
Connie - still tied down to the pond to
b2 and eat through does King do you
who's the b-pawn and 2 seconds left he
barely got that move off night wins
Julian or c3 yeah
maybe and then I looked back to b3 those
double connected passers gonna be a
force to be reckoned with I don't see
anything better than that
Teddy's desperately searching but he's
gotta watch his own clock a ping g5 he
just he's afraid to make a decision here
he doesn't wanna do any committal and
where's his king going now 92 b2 where
is the King going back to c5 he seems a
little bit aimless here he is in seconds
he was a realized that he needs to play
for a win here King of 5 and you're
gonna see Jenny or unto you for now
those pawns collapse this is oh yeah
okay one beat you know 95 95 before oh
you're right there's 95 but he goes like
a bee when they talk to might be 2 to 3
thank pawn oh man he's now an IKE oh
he's gone again and this is gonna be a
repetition I'm this is gonna be our
petition no oh my god goes for it let me
place for a win here we'll take speak to
a kh3 he can hide behind that pawn rook
takes either check and then it's showing
zero showing his discomfort with time
scrambles so we saw him win a couple of
games in the three minute portion but up
on the clock and that does the
heartbreakers you cannot afford
especially if someone as talented his
letters rosin him and bullet but credits
Teddy Coleman because he blundered in
exchange and then after that he
outplayed levy pretty smoothly so
it's a back and forth affair and Levy
showing nerves of steel at this moment
here can he keep it up though boggers
indeed and that was just and we see
Teddy just taking the glasses off
leaning back in his chair such a
disappointment but with bullet you get
an immediate chance to come back the way
he was playing the speed at the start
all of that was good
he's got to keep that but that delivery
he's spent a little bit too long
hesitating between the king moves and
the plans it's easy for me to say but
he's doing all the right things here but
Levy now he's gonna play e5 he's got
another pretty solid position unless you
can play D takes e5 and Queen takes d5
that's what I was looking at is that
pawn on d5 a goner here Queen 65 what
okay Teddy going to end game which maybe
isn't the worst choice in the world and
he's making certain decisions too
quickly and that sounds weird to say we
weren't talking about bullet but you
know I'm what worried about his time
management but I'm worried that he's
going to quickly and levy on the other
hand is consistently down on the clock
he wants to lead Bishop age three but it
comes F for distracting the Queen from
the pin while protecting the G to square
you're at four that's just the move
there's no other move inside only fire
then as out of a cannon Queen g4 there's
rook up three yeah rook get three and
probably takes up four and then Bishop
h7 shot are you oh and King h8 there's
rook h3 and yeah you see what I'm going
for three you see the same page we're
vibing there he goes rook e1 for the end
game but not tactically alert at
Centennial but rookie a rookie aids and
you can't take the rook no you can't in
fact I'm just gonna have fun and okay
but now the white is to truly take mr.
pepper very good move because
rookie seven though there's rook up
seven I think actually I should be free
Bishop e3 is Bishop d3 watch out for
your ropes and e2 and f1 so a good move
there by levy but just take the bishop
and go g4 or something but I've got to
say Teddy's he's just hesitating a
little bit he's not seizing those
tactical opportunities I feel like
that's that might seriously cost him and
it's cost it of gear he's still up on
time though he's got a very small but
significant edge here both on the clock
and on the positional levees doing a
good job of neutralizing what comes to
d7 and
37 can start turning things around but
maybe tell you once it'll work be a trip
b7 just plant that rook and Annoying
screwing the white king which I go to f3
and in so we might see a drop by
repetition and Teddy take hey oh we're
getting a pawn in game but what to make
lessons there's h5 oh my gosh and q g5
yes great outside passed pawn so if you
go King g3 and then you end up taking on
g4 with the king I gotta have five and
five there though
f5 immediately fi five now here it is
and GH and King up for the stone Wow
would an idea I'm Sam that's a to find
that so is black the one who is better
here it's got to be black blacks got
more extra moves here and black is
winning kink f5 and King g4 can I get my
kid no I can't get my King back around
in time that was there's only one pawn
on the Queen side maybe you could talk
about making a draw with two pawns
that's squarely favorites black yes
because you can sue King F - how is that
King getting out Age 4 well you're gonna
eat 3 b3 b3 that's a very good move just
using that one King f3 King back up -
how do we count this both 5 Oh and that
zoogs one night she saved a move that
was really g3 and King runs over to the
other flank classical way of victory and
Teddy needs to resign right now and he
needs he's gonna struggle in this bullet
portion we all know that but he needs to
save that time the mascot says just
under 17 minutes plenty of time left but
you know you have to score right now all
of a sudden levees up a point but it's
been a topsy-turvy stick matters here in
this bullet
levy goes back to his little London type
of thing with Katrina Bishop to g3 and I
like this position for black I do as
well
I myself play a lot of these now DC and
Bishop d3 is a good move here preparing
e4 tani can't lose so here he's staying
in these games he's he's having good
positions it's so incredibly
debilitating and credit to lobby he is
making lemonade out of lemons I mean
he's getting so many of these dubious
positions and handling them very very
precisely to make chances the way he
handled that endgame particularly
impressive finding that t4 idea yes and
Teddy could have been a draw right he
was repeating moves and then it said
using I see
my opponents time trouble I'm playing
for more and that's actually advice I
was just giving in the previous game
where you have to play for it and now
the big Teddy's pawns all the cross with
the 5th rank here that's that's an
unpleasant little shot Knight comes to
b5 Bishop e6 very alert but now Bishop
e2 maybe and then Knight a 7 who does
that work c4 click hey take on Besant
and he wanted rugby 1 or some night a7
just go vanetti 7 getting rid of this
night that maybe c4 again though gosh
that's so frustrating to see for for
black I don't really want to play that
move part 2 Bishop takes b5 though I
don't see anything wrong with that
because rugby one there is bishop takes
a four where's konista where sleep if
except for one there two rooks for the
Queen it should've taken on the floor
was interesting now Knight b6 Knight b6
is nice gonna have to learn B I would go
rook b6 their son 92 92 there's a good
for Gandhi too indeed but he's just
gonna go 97 next trade Queens and try to
win that position yeah let me I'm sure
levy has identified 92 he's trying to
find out does he deal with the dizzy
play a5 and Bank on some crazy activity
that can't be sounds does he play the
forward to try to get under minded
defense of the pawn he chooses the
level-headed rook to on a now night
before very strong move the Queen
straight of course and blacks favor that
bond on e3 adds insult to injury this
this is looking good for Teddy just take
only three 93 93 or 1993 and Teddy's
gonna play 93 he's got to make a
decision though he's got to be decisive
this is what's haunting him these long
things yeah now he's down ten seconds
and he's the one who struggled time for
Queen c4 just try to trade Queens there
it plays it went over Queen b6 the 93 is
hanging so Queen d7 played wait can I
drop the Queen did b8 he's thinking
about her but he's getting himself to a
long time 27:20 70s attack c3 yep and
quit see something that is wrong move at
trading the Queen's might for scuzz
Queen d7 man names just Brooks's yeah
night at five just go Knight a5 retreat
that Knight attack the bishop on g3 you
have to play quickly
Queen c6 repeat at once and gone out of
five yeah you cannot make a draw here
and keeps trying to find a way to trap
the Queen I think f5 very good practical
chance now Queen d4 he's still in the
game his meditation work oh he found a
nice Mickey he could have won a night
there with Quinn h6 and then takes ba
what is
do you hear me to push the pawn Knight
si - what dozen of these come he
separates this is just over by go
somewhat faster Bishop g7 Queen h6 but
it's not in time and did it take anyone
I'm me I'm gonna go back to CT on Queen
takes g1 take thanks
no no fish should be chaining back to
the salmon but he's a draw
oh my goodness oh my gosh what a what a
find and he had that one chance to go
Knight see - he wasted time with rook b8
oh my gosh he was just completely
showing the analysis sports at one time
and bulla we have to show in the
analysis board because right before the
end there there was here Knight to c2
and Bishop AJ trying to mate on g7
instead of create a fake Queen g1 King G
1 a1 equals new Queen and after King F -
there's mate on e1 but we don't have
enough time to look at this that was a
missed opportunity and said we were back
here with levy in 1 point lead and
crudos - Teddy for getting many chances
in this bullet portion but he's not
converting and that could be the tail of
this magic if the score is upheld with a
+1 or maybe more for levy there's 5th oh
there's so many chances that teddy was
missing and levy was pouncing he
defended that position with crazy amount
of tenacity and somehow he survived it
it should fade Shay Bishop g7 brilliant
idea again to find it under these
nervous conditions is is incredible and
that's a very unusual repetition of that
Bishop coming to it I've seen that
before but again to find that in the
snap of a finger
absolutely kudos to levy Teddy's got
another pleasant position though this
one I think probably closer to equality
but again a 5 in Teddy's comfort sauce
just bishop at 595 coming and you're
gonna have a oh yeah night it gets a bad
why it's better yeah there's about
five just just play that move very tip
no you're going the wrong right way
you're just saying you can go your own
way
it's a b5 Queen deficient by five again
Bishop F up now is even more powerful
because the knight Canon Inc
he's just playing a little too slowly
you know F photo that's a risky move it
is we let me do that before now those
dark squares 95 manage for g3 is very
very alert it's not being upon oh gosh
you're opening at the board after
playing f5 that feels like a wrong
choice here
and Teddy quickly says don't mind if I
do now the position is up Queenie five
is one move just to say hey we trade
Queens your pawns or just flimsy on a
foreign and see we d5 an f5 and what's
our for D for at some moment if that
Bishop can open up there can be a
counter shop in the fish Plato says hey
your D pawn is pinned so Queen before is
one idea to training the Queen's off and
going after the d5 pawn I like Queen d4
but Queen 683 was it moved there
Queen takes a 7 just look but now Queen
a3 he's gotta go Queen f3 tried to raise
some complications here and Teddy's got
to play fast be still my beating heart
this is rook C 737 rook c7 words a piece
but a 2 is 2 8 2 is hang I 2 is veggies
right and f2 is hanging after that so
the problem is you would love to never
take an eye - what now - come b7 you go
to between either
there should be one I like that you're
attacking a5 Bishop see a take on c8 and
play Bishop a5 or take on a 7 I think
also at seven looks good - and he takes
a nice m200 lezzy want to see seven
minutes time trouble we do seven me
oh it's mean one finds it he sees it
that is a time matchup and Levy once
again on just the cusp of losing on time
and Teddy takes advantage in that game
so we have a tied match once more I
really don't think my heart can take it
Dani is still still my beating heart I
mean this is fascinating once again
again and again Robert we're seeing
these crazy matches I can feel my heart
just pumping it is pumping what's going
on here that puzzle I mean but I think
this is actually aligned where you go
night a4 and then you try to undermine
it with a 3 and 95 this is actually a
legitimate line of but obviously g5 I
think this is a bad decision by both
players for a bully cam and that sounds
like a ridiculous thing to say but every
single move you have to think wait am I
about to lose is this happening like
what's going on here and 95 so play h6
if Bishop f6 GF 6 even wait you know
Vicki yeah I hope nobody's mom made them
spaghetti because this is gonna be a
very wild finish takes now we get this
weird structure without pawn on f6
you like levees got these practical
chances connected with with this control
forward the Queen side scores III
developing the Queen and potentially to
g4 I like
Chetty maybe he's going to castlelong in
c5 watch out castle on 8 v f7 hangs and
a5 it's hard to actually get done
Oh f5 I actually didn't like Oh Teddy go
Bishop a6 to b5 at some point said he
just immediately plays for c5 and well
the Bishop's getting traded should help
black and sense of white King might be a
little more vulnerable and but where's
the downside d6 is defended here so
there's no Knight to d6 check I'd okay
but this is so this is this is dicey
because 95 95 Bishop c5 been a be tears
open that a file still black hangs on a
B I don't quite have a knight takes beef
3 he does it wow what is going on here
my eyes are this is crazy one in the
Navy who is better here I did you pick
c5 oh they don't equal Bishop because
it's negative 66 which is Queen da no
Ruby one that pins the night to me
Queenie 7 huh just go Queenie 7 I think
and there it is protecting the point of
7 making your Wow closer your King makes
your keen feel safe king of fate is okay
but a queen h6 check King g8 your
smoochie gonna be one from the other
side the problem is rugby one there's
Knight takes d5 and the night loses its
support how it is levee do here and rook
e1 was just a four so here F 1 and C 2
okay we'll take a look C 3 there's Queen
d6 simultaneously defending the knight
on c5 oh I can't even draw my arrows
then the 96 is hanging here so 33 - and
there's no drug because if I take on
these sick my king will escape to e7 he
was Knight to c4 back now 94 80 for
stabilizing everything the right is 92
next 802
a pretty decent because now you got that
a pawn or 95
I like 95 and he puts some pretty tough
to reach to c8 the knight is pinned on
a5 and how does it get out c2 or 95 ok
95 94 994 de Grandy negative 3 and rook
da before pixie 3 so the puzzle from C
593 night that gets out 9 I don't like
rook c5 ok I think though probably it
should be it's close c2 d2 99022 92 is a
huge star I don't see a defense 1992 oh
we missed it
he missed missed it but now that night
I take it upon take the after he was
hanging dances there okay five three
seconds can you be excited Mexican whoa
oh man what if what if see because I was
at the blend of that to h5 played five
easy losing the thread a little bit
still completely winning though see one
Queen a threat kingi for oh gosh the
nets under attack now now you finally
ninety-two and he fine does it and check
by levee rookie one King g6 just go in
for sixty two nice try but levee and
take tonight now take tonight simplify
simplify simplify simplify
rooks III or f3 works as well tonight
there it it no forms this is winning and
you buy levy understanding the match
clock saying I need as much time as
possible eyes hey wise by levy you did a
one-game lead for Teddy I thought
honestly that it was out of his control
once he went down the point levy being
stronger than two bullet players but
it's clear that Teddy Coleman is
underrated with the one sec hippie in
comin on the clock and right now a
one-point lead for Teddy Coleman is
knight on c6 Danya we've seen this
before I don't like it it's in front of
the C pawn you would like to a c5 hit
the d4 pawn and try to fight against
White's better center but right now with
the ninety six in front of the pond
you're not getting that activity indeed
we've seen this before
levy probably banking on e5 and I have
to say Teddy's hard on himself you can
tell by his facial reaction he's never
quite satisfied with the quality of his
games but he is playing his heart out
and I don't think I think no one
expected this he's playing fast he's
playing accurately he's keeping himself
composed in time pressure with that
being said five and a half minutes left
levy needs to win only one game in the
mattress tied and that was a mistake by
Teddy ninety-four you cannot recover
those 31 this review one be sure before
you leave rookie oh no the oldest 85 ah
there's B five now is very clever indeed
I don't know what you do but there
should be fives a nice move hard to play
when you're walking into a pin but he
plays it mr. g4 and then f4 hey my
twelve six he's trying to what a move
wow what a find it d3 I just try to move
my rook to be one of them school yeah
but is d3 rugby what I can already move
my Queen 87 because then after half four
I'll have Quincy five check but I do win
back the deep on so that's the good news
for white so you know vision may try the
clever response do you give up your
rooks I don't think so Queen III Bishop
a1 yeah that's
because black has that control over the
dark squares that's super important so
wait why don't work Siwon why wait ship
t4 uh that wait now that's the free
queen bee five excellent move by levy
here that looks really bad rooks before
is it the right with d3 pawn falling so
maybe white is somehow holding on that
was a good move Bishop to b6 I hope that
Bishop f3 and she's also gonna pay for a
494 on oh it's all so good before divine
to Bishop a5 yet d2 first you're right
d2 now as well driving that wedging yes
ladies gotta be careful though Teddy's
starting to slowly pile up on the Kings
side and b4 doesn't work as the Brooklyn
III Zangler rook chief sorry is that
we're gonna look at trying to get a
quick check I mean uh 47 Queens like
what's is wrong look she did it seven he
fell out Victini shape Robert King okay
Queenie h5 then all you do we eat was
Queen on me it's yeah and then Queen
takes g3 but I have 14 you treat Bishop
c2 and you Oh Queen h5 goes for five is
mate this is Dolan draw his mate so the
King can't go to f6 I was freaking out
they're so close though and maybe is
smart he's just gonna you just gotta
make a draw he does and he has more time
oh my gosh man dude I can't handle this
anymore this is this is oh look at Teddy
he's waiting he's gonna wait for the
last second to play Queenie try check
he's gonna ice the kicker that's savvy
savvy strategy but there's more than
enough time though and there he does he
makes he goes down to five seconds
that's what you do right you call that
time out for that game-winning field
goal you give yourself a couple of
seconds so you don't flag and wow what a
game still a one-point match in Teddy
Coleman's favor we see another London
system will he go back to the juban
variation or is he going to play
something different
Danya 95-96 always is the wrestler Blair
Walsh should blunder a queen here but
levy as I've said he knows that it keeps
up keep himself composed he's gotten
good positions out of the Jew Bob London
at that move
c5 followed by u6 that night on b5 is a
splinter it can be supported with a four
I've seen this this line in the Women's
World Championship between Gary ashkani
and you and you
this is very very complicated position
but white should be slightly better
here's got more space it's easier to
play white here teddy spending a lot of
time in the opening yeah you have to go
a certain point if you trust yourself
you can anybody not each file which I
think ultimately this is a good choice
because he's mixing it up if you leave
the status quo what has more space as
you point out the nine mp5 is so strong
take on g3 not yet because then bishop
in the age from age seven point so I
will hear or g6 supporting the t6 mm-hmm
so the kind of female go you don't have
to take just yet but Bishop h4 might be
a threat just avoid it and try to put G
for himself so he does now take any
castles Bishop d3 can omit my c4 and
what's that queen-sized closes I go next
e7 and then you have no attack on my
king so Y can also calmly place III
followed by Queen c2 that's what levy
decides to do keep the tension now he
can play Bishop d3 because c4 he's
opened up that diagonal he can play
Bishop c2 and even potentially Queen B 1
I'm looking at f5 for black because f5
Bishop f6 you know I give the e5 score
temporarily and then I just what about
night 74 I wrote page 74 roll cages 95
and roll cage 7 there's not only so d7
right no I take your rook and move my
King out the way exactly you don't have
to take everything I don't I'm not that
greedy I would love to take your free
pieces but not all 3 when it lands me
and check me but right now Teddy 17
seconds and counting down 9 h 4f v you
got to play out 5 sure up your king he
does that and I took a lady's attack
going to continue you need to play a g4
type of move but your king is so in the
center
he's going to be too little she for very
risky but oh man what's who's king is is
safer I think both Kings are very
uncomfortable here Queen f6 could be a
nice stabilizing move so I take an e3
look at this who do next and then the
Kings got to hide behind the pawn so by
Queen f6 Melbourne NGH actually I don't
like decision by Teddy he should have
just kept things closed he goes for this
yeah can't do the same thing g7 maybe
good moon g7 cuz queen chief or there's
Queen g5 oh look at for Queen g5 become
next one actually six now rotation six
streams in there's always right time for
Teddy that's a good move though stopping
rip it chicks now rush a dive he's
pre-movie Bishop takes at four so in
there he does he gets the pre moving to
eat sometime a 5:35 hostname but I still
154 is a threat in the key g7 for cafe
he's gonna make a move queer
goodbye teddy take it and the King g7
don't blend your when you're now
almost in what's the count
we got a double-edged exchange up for
women for one blonde we've seen Teddy
work as we have this kind of look at
that night though 94 coming that a for
threat as well work on Wednesday night
it went another pawn rook b1 b2 c3 6b 5d
4d for push that thing that's it and
taking G 6 96 94 was an Isaiah Berlin
destabilizes the night take up these
only to how many extra paws is he having
a routine check coming and this is the
last game of the match babies SS yeah
that's the last evening to check whoopsy
193 coming in this is a oh my gosh oh my
god I just got obey the checks it looks
over and got away the checks is making
the Queen and just go just go just make
much we did to Queen c2 Queen d3 even a
perpetual system and you have to make
these pre moves you just have to go g4
he's just got to go fast and there it is
Teddy wins
Barrett any wins Wow oh my gosh Teddy
cried somehow wins this match in a
bullet brawl the match is over we will
get the player such I cannot believe it
Levin the most fascinating endings we
needed magic to happen and he couldn't
go full Wingardium Leviosa men he does
not save this match and Teddy Cole moves
on to Sammy's we need a breather I mean
seriously
my vocal cords my heart hurt we will be
right back and just we will with the
players on call for a post match
interview
[Music]
and as we returned with the players I
just want to thank you both Levy and
Teddy on what was an epic match and
Teddy we have to start with you are you
doing this on purpose are you just
trying to get down to the wire and every
single matchup and just make it as
exciting as humanly possible and believe
me if I had the ability to make it less
just one myself I would sadly I don't
but uh yeah I mean obviously live a
great match you know I thought I was in
trouble in the bullet but it you know
somehow kept it together congratulations
to Teddy and Levy you put together some
absolutely incredible fights with
virtually no time left on your clock
what do you feel went wrong in the
bullet section if you had to play that
match over again what are your sort of
immediate thoughts about what didn't
quite go your way
probably just time management I mean it
was pretty obvious that I you know even
the 5:1 I found myself in crazy time
trouble I mean I think the comfort zone
of playing a lot of no increment blitz
and bullet just in general always makes
you play faster and then here you're
just constantly double-checking things
that normally you would be making moves
immediately like this last game is a is
a great example I think this is a kind
of week I think I swindled Teddy far
more I think he was just better in so
many more positions but it just shows
you that you know even but there also
was a game that like Teddy completely
came back like 10 seconds versus 1
minute it's just you you always kind of
have that safety barrier and I just
don't know just if I had to do something
over I wouldn't have Teddy as my
opponent well Teddy back to you for a
second here what was your preparation
like for the match because while we're
calling it I was looking at your
triangle pawn structure and be like some
of these openings don't seem so Teddy
Coleman like from my recollection yeah
yeah no the triangle was something that
was also a bit of a project
I actually wasn't expecting it in the
match so when you played it in the first
game you know there's the I played a 93
check which kind of simplifies very
quickly into an end game and then
obviously there's 11 legacy to check
where like we take each other's rooks
crazy things start happening and since I
couldn't really like remember what the
right thing was I kind of bailed out
early on so yeah I mean I think in the
match I was I constantly felt like levy
perhaps a really annoying openings and
and didn't quite especially with black I
never quite felt like I was where I
wanted to be so it was yeah I thought it
was a really interesting preparation
well Teddy a bit of a humorous question
but obviously we're chowing down that
shook shook oh and that avocado toast we
didn't see you eating too much this time
that a conscious decision was that
propagated by Teddy Coleman's
better-half
explain that for us shakshuka
and then there was oranges and some
carrot cake and just like I don't know I
feel like I I attacked the oranges and
just to get some sugar
no avvocato test this time sorry I've
got my Californians you failed the Bay
Area well people have to forgive you and
I mean levy yeah you know that match was
just amazing it's you you're up two
games earlier in the match and the
five-minute portion at that point did
you feel confident are you still feeling
a little wobbly because most of the
games were coming down to time scrim
yeah no that was like a super shake
comfort zone because in the fourth game
you know Teddy let me play him so I was
happy to do that and then he like even
in this ridiculous line where you
sacrificed like a pawn or two and get
play he was just blitzing all these
moves I was like what the hell okay
it felt like I don't know I mean maybe I
I don't know to what degree he wants to
you know spoil how just how many
openings he knows but it just felt nuts
like I couldn't play into anything where
my move you know ten fifteen I was just
blitzing out moves it just kept like you
know felt like he was just making me
work every single game so then the
strategy became alright let's let's get
out of five one you know up a game or
equal turn it over to three one the
three one felt like very back and forth
except toward the end you know he took a
lead and then I clutched it out that
I mean probably if I lose that game I
lose the match I did lose a match but
and then I was like okay one game margin
in the bullet is fine and then Teddy
just kept it going it was just like he
was finding these you know just just out
playing the game by game was like okay
there's nothing I can do so you know
yeah at the end of the three one I did a
hangman again although this summer
wasn't made in one it was made in like
maybe it's an unfortunate trend I need
to stop doing I'm sorry let me go I was
just gonna say like you know throughout
the match you're looking to identify
your opponent's weaknesses like okay
openings it's not the openings it's also
not really the time I mean the time
scram was a little bit but think he was
getting me and sometimes scrambles like
all right his only weakness is that I
play long enough maybe he hangs me small
chance monster card is kryptonite and
today I do want to ask you a question so
for those people you know many thousands
of viewers who've been watching they may
not be so familiar with you you want to
tell people a little bit about your day
job because you're playing chess isn't
your full-time profession yeah yeah so
right now I'm sort of a software
engineer at a startup so very very San
Francisco but yeah I mean obviously I
played very seriously growing up and
then my first year out of college I
played chess and that year was a 2011 in
2012 which I played with Mark Arnold and
that's when I got my IM title and since
then I've been much more of a chess
hobbyist I guess and it kind of comes
and goes in waves where sometimes I'll
find that I have a lot of time to work
on chess or not but um I mean it
definitely something that I wish I had
more time for and you know could play in
more tournaments well I've got a beef
San Francisco and be a jerk for one
second to Teddy why is it that your
bullet rating is I mean you played on a
twenty six twenty seven hundred level do
you feel like that increments
significantly changes the way that you
play because we might need to move you
out of the bay area if you don't cross
2,500 soon no for sure I think that
increment is like so so so different so
like after I put the magic in standing I
played some more bullet camp who's just
trying to get used to like
you know playing that but nobody on the
unjust icon wants to play one one
everyone wants to play one oh and I'm
just like flagging all the time because
I'm I'm too slow so that the increment
just saves me so much and you know I was
living on it in a lot of games you were
indeed and somehow you were living on
the edge and still move on levy I know
it's not the results you wanted but we
need to thank you profusely for an
entertaining match all of your fans were
shouting for you as much as they can on
their keyboards and they love themselves
in Gotham chess I'll continue to watch
levy here on twitch and he's great
Chet's ahead for him and Teddy
congratulations you surprised everybody
by winning some games on time but you do
move on to the semi-finals so
congratulations to you too both and
thank you so much thank you guys thank
you and as we see here we have one half
of the bracket filled out we have the
semi-final match up ahead between Alina
castle Scylla the winner earlier today
over Eric Rosen she will take on Teddy
Coleman who just won another thriller
not a Manilla but still Teddy Coleman
just happens to you know he keeps on the
edge of our seats he's won two of our
closest matchups and now he beats levy
Rosen to moving the semi so Danya I mean
what a day we've had here Teddy just
what can we say about Teddy comb and his
ability to come through in moments where
it seems like the Mattress of being away
from well he has blessed us with some
absolutely incredible action that match
against Danny I'm just still thinking
about the way that he composed himself
for that tie break and scored to those
two knockout wins at the start and here
as well adjusting his speed showing
himself capable of matching the very
very best at bullet he's going to be
preparing hard for that match against
Alina who is an absolute beast in her
own right as she showed this morning
against Eric that is going to be a
scintillating match and I just want to
personally thank both Teddy and Levy
levy just an amazing sport obviously
painful loss but he came out explained
as much as he could that's certainly not
easy to do so we thank both of these
players who are not only amazing a chess
but just class acts and make commentary
very very fun I mean we could have asked
we could have scripted a better match we
had ourselves a blast
Danya you know we throw friendly barbs
at each other fun of each other but
honestly it's just the best time coming
to a match like this with you and thank
you to all of our view like whether
you're watching on chess TV twitch
YouTube Facebook I don't know where
you're watching from but thank you so
much for tuning in you make these shows
happen and the players really
appreciates not just us I've talked to
all of them and just seeing their names
you cheer for them and they're putting
not just their chess kills on the line
but their blood sweat and tears and
their whole heart into these matches so
thank you so much for supporting the
players for supporting us and for
supporting chess on that note have a
great night
have a great morning if you're somewhere
and it's already morning and please
enjoy because tomorrow we will be back
with another doubleheader and this time
we will have John Bartholomew taking on
Lawrence Trent charissa yep taking on
Gregg jihadi and Donnie and I just
recovering in the meantime because I
mean we were just on our vocal cords are
out the window
sokka thank you thank you thank you
everybody ganya thanks to you I know I
don't show my appreciation for you
enough but I am really appreciative that
you're along siding for the riots okay
Finn a great night and we'll be by K
Longmore well thank you everyone goodbye
[Music]